helping guys who were doing and welcome
to a brand new video tutorial this is my
new video actually on the freaking camp
it's not my boot and hopefully you can
actually enjoy industry as a much leader
in making this and creating the
application you're gonna do today so for
this one we're gonna probably do is
create a really awesome and cool react
weather application so we're gonna just
go ahead stop by step by step from
scratch start up a project created react
application and create all the different
components and stuff like this put them
together with the CSS styles and
different things actually to be handled
and we are actually gonna go ahead and
go through creating a full weather
application with restful api and we're
gonna just go in and use some things
actually some help from api so actually
public api using the restful HTTP api is
like this api xu so we can get the
weather data in the forecast for
probably a couple of days actually and
if recurrence weather data for any city
we wants for example we want the current
city that we are actually in and we can
get all the different data something if
you don't know me it is actually my
learn your website open is calm and
hopefully you can govern and check out
all the channels down there so we can
have like millions of other stories like
this really also called stories and
stuff like that the other one for web
development so they're gonna try to get
started so the final application or the
prototype we're gonna work on this is
actually the things as we try to achieve
throughout this tutorial so hopefully
you can just go ahead and imagine this
in your head i've tried to put a
prototype together in here just a quick
one using a thick amount so for those of
you who doesn't know fit my figmas just
like a prototyping tool you can just go
to figma calm its you're pretty pretty
nice for to prototype into you could go
ahead and just go and use it if even
though you're not that much of UX design
or something it simplifies your life as
a web developer ahchiminie gives you a
lot of over cool awesome features that
you can be use to prototype such an
application so actually here we've got
the weather title with
got the location name it's gonna
probably basically just your location
name like London or something we've got
you know number of degrees or the actual
currents
weather and we've got whether it's sunny
or it's dark for example it since it's
nice just gonna show a logo or an image
of like darkness like a moon to show up
that we are actually at night otherwise
we show a Sun so we are pretty much
today and we sell them like even it's
sunny or within some clouds or partially
cloudy or something there's something
specifically for a weather application
and the weather forecast and everything
we could also have just simply this one
this little tiny botany and that allows
you to select a lot probably a location
we can just go and click that and get a
pop-up and we can actually search for a
location we said to the name of the
location and there we go the locations
is gonna go ahead and change jump or
layout up in the background we're gonna
try to make all of that from scratch and
hopefully if you actually enjoy that and
get the experience behind creating like
a really awesome application using react
even though you're actually new you
still need to actually follow up the
story and try to figure out how things
are actually working behind the scenes
and in the future part in here or the
bottom part what we're gonna probably do
is just like you know show the forecast
for the couple of next days like the for
next days or something like this you're
gonna show what is going on in the next
couple of days
like Sunday Monday you've got the point
actually and the Celsius degrees with me
use refers or Celsius
I prefer soleus in this case like you
know more details about the weather for
this particular days like whether it's
sunny or cloudy or whatever thing I've
got pretty much the point of how weather
application works so let's go ahead and
try to get it started for reax
application if you are a reactive
although you probably heard about reused
create react app the command-line tool
that allows which creates quickly and
set up applications or reacts projects
very very easily without any hassles or
problems or that much of calm Croatia so
I'm gonna use creates um we
up so probably you need to open up a
chairman over here or you can even use
CMD if your windows I'm using surrender
in here and you create a backup I'm
gonna put whether up okay
simple as that I just type in this one
and it's probably just going to start
creating the for us and it downloads and
resolve dependencies like the reacts
reacts script and in different packages
that allows us to do so and there we go
these setup and the creation of the
project has been successfully done no we
can just govern it use our favorite
editor to start working on the
application I'm gonna use Visual Studio
code it's just you know but very awesome
in very in because you can use whatever
ID you pretty much like so I'm gonna
just going inside of the weather upper
folder that has been created for us from
the query act up so I and I'm just gonna
use the code to open it just type in
code dance and it opens this project on
a brand new instance of video 0 code so
waiting for it it's just the project
yo-yoed and everything and hopefully
everything can pretty much work fine so
first exposed to do whenever you create
a reacts project especially using the
create reacts up see a line is actually
to test it and try to just go ahead and
stop run the start script to see
actually what is going on behind the
scenes so let me just get rid of that
and we really need anymore I'm gonna
open up a new terminal instance of the
integrator terminal from visual studio
code and okay now let's try to run the
script which is MBM one star so we can
you know make sure that the application
has been set up and created successfully
without any problems or missing
dependencies or something so we can stop
developing the application without any
problems
so I actually decided to start the
development process of this particular
application from the scratch like by
creating projects and show you
everything going on behind the scenes so
probably when people faces ears that
doesn't know actually how to go or how
to start or something like this so yeah
they would have a problem and they would
try to fix it by just you know following
up from from just the beginning from
scratch and just to make you guys feel
comfortable following it along with this
and there we go so the service actually
is starting without any problems NPN
didn't actually threw up any error or
yeah no exception or also everything
hopefully works pretty much fine take a
look the application this is actually
the main up DoDEA's file so we can
actually use this for it's the main
component size being rendered so I can
wait for a couple of seconds actually to
make this actually running ro is taking
quite some time there we go and there we
go we've got the application working in
the boiler panel is actually running
Malhar any problems or issues so now
we've got to simply just go ahead and
start working on the application so
starting off let's just try to this it's
our application if you take a look I'm
gonna I'm gonna use actually the
prototype a lot let me just zoom in here
you can clearly see what's going on I'm
gonna create first the container or the
actual main components that I'm gonna
pass all the prompts to this particular
data so in this case I'm gonna create a
try I'm gonna create a new file and I'm
gonna use some kind of a flocks
he likes the flock state management
you're probably familiar with it or not
it just like a design pattern for Reax
applications that allows you to pass
data between props very very easily as
we know that you can only pass data from
a parent to a child not a vice-versa
thing like passing it from a channel to
a parent so we actually need some global
data to be access from the old actual
components that is being rendered in the
hierarchy and on the other hand we can
have like a main up state that holds the
Upstate actually of all components like
the shared up state between all the
different components of any components
in the hierarchy any components being
rendered on our application can actually
access the theater and alter the DNA and
set the states and change all different
things so it's your really really
important thing to know even though our
applications is very basic straight to
the point it doesn't really need the
Flex design parent but I just want to
point you guys get to I'm gonna use it
in this one for you actually guys
take lay along the source code and just
develop it take it to the next level add
more features to it and make it just a
real word weather application so you can
easily edit the features without any
problems whenever you find it's actually
already being built on top of this
design pattern so I'm gonna name this
for example it's gonna be the store so
why I'm naming a store because it stores
the critical global up States so yeah
Sorge is it's gonna be a normal
component so I'm just gonna go in and do
like import reacts
okay from well we act and I'm gonna do
well yeah it's gonna be a normal
reaction phone I'm just gonna do export
default and try ok so it's gonna be
class I'm gonna create a class in here
get a Nima's store and it's gonna extend
doesn't normally you react stock
components ok there we go and it's gonna
be having a constructor or something you
can initialize any data you can passing
props to this contracta structure which
is not really that much of a big deal
but we are still worth having in here we
can have like a made-up state in here
which is like it's gonna be it so and I
can give you a hint about comments in
this like main up States ok and we can
have a render function and what we want
is all of the children that's gonna be
inside of that is actually or any
children that we're gonna pass to this
one it's gonna render it just inside the
store we can have passed to them the
stage we haven't here whatever data you
have in here for example try to put
something I like the name or like the
application name and I'm just gonna put
like the application name is gonna be
weather up so yeah and here we try to
return whatever like props dot children
think but this doesn't actually how it
works what you want is to take the state
every single piece of data that is
inside of this date or the state that
we're having is we just need to pass it
down into the hierarchy so whatever the
child is gonna get it is gonna get it as
a props so to do so we're gonna just
he used the help of props and children
alongside react clone elements function
or the method that allows us to clone
elements very very easily into
components surpassing the promise tone
so here I'm gonna like return and it's
gonna be a math function just gonna use
react dots well children and for this
reactive children I'm gonna use the map
function so the map function you need to
pass it whatever the child so we can do
react children so we need to access the
props I totally forgot about I thought I
may use it is stateless components and
we can actually render that here and
what I wish to use well we've gotten us
to use issue in here so clearly
something is actually going on but yeah
so I think we having me take a look at
this one map components to can actually
children okay so he's just a passing the
children in my bad here so they stop
drops of children and the next thing it
takes a call back with a child and we
can use this whole just screwing up keys
right now so you probably see me typing
it really weird air things and just
stupid errors anyway so here we can use
the child what we gonna probably return
for each single charm gonna be passed
into this we're gonna probably just
surrender one single child is gonna be
the up components that we're gonna
render inside of this so I'm gonna
return and I'm gonna return like relax
don't clone elements and this clone
elements it takes an actual elements
which is gonna be the child so the child
is actually a real word react valve
element and it takes the second thing of
seriously here it takes whatever props
you want to pass into this child and it
just creates a brand-new components with
this prompts
being passed into so the perhaps you
want is for example is actually the
states that we have in up there so I can
easily need to retake this state
I'm gonna do this thoughts states and
you make sure to relate this using this
expand symbol thing or the the actual
expand objects iterator in here so just
to like you know merge an objects this
is an object with another objects and
why I'm doing it here just merging the
state objects with an empty object so he
can create a different object rather
than state so here free trade just to
pass in the states just gonna pass in
the reference of the state we don't want
dance wanna mutates the actual state and
pass it down to the child so you can
have the same props as we do for the
actual state so it's gonna be simple as
that everything in here is gonna have
the up name whatever we add in here it's
just gonna be right over there so yeah
it's a pretty good departure in here
it's basically not the best thing you
can have you can you have redox on the
flux flux actually have many different
ways to be implemented on so it's just a
very basic in a very efficient way I
actually have and they use a lot of my
other projects so hopefully you can
actually like here and everything this
is just simply the storage is now we can
jump back into the upload is probably
home for the whole rendering I don't
need any of this and I could just get
rid weight of it and what it wants to
say I need the styling so I'm just gonna
put another file so if God's in here or
is it actually the store inside they
also see I'm gonna put another folder
named its ass this is gonna hold our
sass files and for actually working with
sass and in odious so or probably query
act app you've got to go ahead and
install know it so to do so you're just
gonna do this so npm install node
- sass make sure to do this if you want
to use less or something you can use the
actual compiler for less but we want to
use sass just only for development
purposes i'm just going to install this
for the powerpoint purposes now actually
have been install so as we now can use
sass very easy so i'm just gonna do it
here I quit in your file I'm gonna name
this probably just up
the SAS so just going to be the main
application style inside of this folder
you can you can have a different ways to
create an instructor but yeah you know
the best thing for me so it's actually
better to change this from js2 gsx so
division co-current al ID can actually
recognize this as a real GS X Files and
it can actually activate some features
for us like emits and we can use some
HTML features or DSX features in this
one or you can easily just go it down
here select count scripts and search for
react Java scripts and change it but I
would like very much to change the name
here and rename it just add in gsx
included see the icon changes into
recognizing gsx or java scripts and
react and probably gonna get another ear
so for this we're gonna probably do is
just simply go to the index or GS and it
doesn't actually recognize any of that I
can just add the GS X in here and
everything should pretty much we're fine
or yep yeah we've got a completely
different worker situation that is
actually happening for this and it still
can actually figure out why but yeah so
if I try to keep quick impalas and BM on
start again yeah we've got a completely
different here which is react scripts
are not defined
welcome mr. Ayers okay so there's a
starting up we'll just try to fix this
with NPM install well we asked our
scripts this sometimes happens when you
actually configure a we create react up
projects then you actually install some
other dependencies as we did just
install the node SAS so it basically I
don't know some kind of really hard bunk
it deletes the react script jury it
removes it from the backdoor JSON so
this is a really really bad thing to do
I should actually submit some issue or
some other people actually should submit
an issue into the actually the github
issues for the query acts up and they
can let the developers fix this as soon
as possible because it's very very
annoying for the Bolton things in here
now actually a friend is working pretty
much finest installing the we have
scripts
just a serious bug anyway so just like
you know rendering a div in here just
for testing purposes and he pretty much
working fine with all your problems that
you can clearly see in here we've got
the react just open up the dev tool so
we can clearly see what's going on
behind the scenes
now we're gonna probably do just you
know put a div in here I'm just gonna
put a div I'm gonna put a class neighbor
a div and let's try to put the class
name I don't know like this is gonna be
the the main container then we're gonna
have just a smaller containers out of it
so it's just gonna mean it like you mean
container okay
and inside of that I'm gonna have is
well another container so I'm just gonna
put another class name which is gonna
hold
well let's name this or let me just
we need this like up container the
problem is actually with renaming so the
majority of problems are naming your
variables and your classes and your IDs
and different things so just to have
them nicely urban brewing and stuff like
this so I'm gonna name like I don't know
where's this name mean container okay
I'm gonna be just here and we can just
go in and play with a sound a little bit
so gonna have to see us a song it's
gonna be the up container first let me
just first put the body and the HTML so
I'm gonna start with HTML and say party
I don't know I need gets an okay I
shouldn't have done that I should name
this as CSS okay no we should work so
barri and it can put 100% okay with it's
gonna be 100% tied gonna be the same sub
hundred percent high as well well we're
just gonna use the Box sizing so I'm
just gonna put box size in to your
portal box this is the best box size in
that you can use actually for your
application it's the best thing actually
for having a smoothie layouts in
responsive design so yeah this is basic
we should have done and try to get our
classes so first I have up contain
yourself and it's sort of it just gonna
use sass are just gonna put inside of
him gonna have me container okay and
he's gonna have like the width of 100%
so under problem is actually with typing
most of the times how yeah 100% as well
and it's very hard actually to type and
talk at the same time so you got look
going through much I'm gonna use flex
display in here just to display things
smoothly you can Center things align
them in the center so what it wants I
want to take this one yeah that fits
opps
okay let me just refresh that what I
want is actually to have them all in the
center in here just the weather
application the whole container of the
application gonna be in the center and
we don't really care about the other
thing that we have so this is what I
mean this just going to be it and the
other one is just like the outside page
so we just only care about the inner
container of the application in here the
weather application is gonna be the main
container I'm gonna have like flex dodge
okay I'm gonna just do justify content
to Center and align points in the center
so we can have it perfectly centered
thinking so let me just refresh that
really correct
hopefully just not including a style
anyway so let me just go ahead and try
to include this style just waiting for
him I'm gonna pour this style they're
just going to sass and up CSS so up door
I CSS there we go
just saving that recompiling in should
now we have them like horizontally
centered but not vertically and most of
the time the problem is actually with
vertically centered so I've got the body
taking the full hinds everything is
taking the full heights but the route is
not so what it wants is just like to add
this the same thing to the ID or fruits
simple as that now there we go we've got
them perfectly centered right over here
in the center and the key
is actually probably just the main
cotugno is actually working fine without
any problems and you can put some
constraints into it so you can put with
and/or a kid with like a minimum width
of that's gonna be I don't know 300
pixels or something something like this
let me just go and copy the pixels of
this this has 993 and you know let's
just gotta try to copy this of the main
with it's quite large so I'm gonna try
to put 600 pixels or something like this
okay that seems that seems pretty decent
it's not really that much of bad and it
can put Heights the highs actually
always fix it and it can put about 400
pixels of height and if you take a look
at that I think it's quite a lot so we
can actually take this two or three
hundred okay um yeah 300 seems quite
decent without any problems so clear you
see in here just the the actual hovering
and the outline is shows pretty good so
we just copy this put them right over
here and it should be much worse I'm
also I'm gonna put a display of flex
into here so we can have this container
as well gonna be flex designed I'm just
gonna add a couple of things a huge is
gonna add for example well I tried to
add some border so we can clear you see
I'm just gonna add the pixel with a
solid and I'm gonna add about 2 to 2 or
let's try a 8 so we can have a distance
okay let's try 99 so we can have a
decent grey here and I'm gonna add a
border radius as well so for a border
busy I'm gonna 3 pixels and I'm gonna
say solid so okay I know add a solid but
I'm going to say 4 pixels or even 3
pixels a little bit much better I'm just
gonna copy everything in here okay just
copying it it's actually a pain just
copy paste in it okay there we go
and my wants adhere to design enough
here to structure the application you
can have two different house the first
half is the top half and we
actually the bottom health and this is
actually the main container so the main
container is gonna be flexed like flexed
box so we're gonna use the display flex
and you're gonna have to split this into
a house so we're gonna have up section
or the top section and the bottom
section both of them so we've got to go
ahead and just add those exactly the
same as we want them so up tortillas and
we can actually go ahead and try to put
them right over there so I'm just gonna
do this is the main container I'm gonna
be here dots top ok section and we're
gonna have another one so it's gonna be
bottom section there we go
and this is gonna be a key to the top so
I'm just gonna put the top on here so we
can like easily structure these things
and we can put them together in on your
problems and probably here we're gonna
use since we want them in rows not
columns so we're gonna change this to
actually flex display or flex direction
tuberose say some clear see the Flex
column Plus remain access has the same
orientation
so there's actually where who wants
would want them actually actually both
columns like this first column and the
second column in here I'm just gonna
save that's and this should hopefully
there we go so this first column the
second column as we said and we've got
the main container in here but it's not
taking the full width how to do so I'm
gonna use the bases or flex main
attribute here to set this I'm gonna set
hundred-percent for both them but
actually it's takes them out of control
so I'm just gonna say 50% out of the
worth so they have the top has the first
top and the bottom actually has what's
left from it I'm just gonna need to copy
this from it and you should pretty much
work fine so I sort of that it's gonna
be the main container I'm just gonna put
this both of them so just just don't
section I'm gonna put flex and also that
the bottom section so and flex right
over there so if you try to refresh that
there we go we've got both of them this
is the top this is the bottom and they
have like a completely separate paths
from from actually you know with
different things in here without any
problems or issues so we've got them
covered successfully though just gonna
try now to work for the top health and
try to to play some actually dear now
that we can actually later or engage and
make it dynamics we just need to put for
now just a static data so later on we
can I don't know hook up or just try to
call an API and give the DN a-- and make
it actually work as a dynamic thing I
was actually you know changes every
single day changes whenever you choose a
location it changes it changes over you
know one time passes and someone on so
forth
so we have to actually visualize a
real-world application or weather
application but for now we just need to
get the DN a-- out there just need to
structure it and start with the CSS like
to put the DN a-- so this is actually
what you want whether you're actually
designer or creating a reacts
application whether another vanilla
JavaScript application any framework
actually using angularjs
so there's actually the steps that I
would like recommend for you guys to go
through for every project for every
application either a simple or a huge
application of course when you're
dealing with larger because you're gonna
need to prototype a lot you get put your
classes inside of like UML or some some
diagrams in order to simplify this kind
of things for you and make them easier
for your actually to reach and
understand the whole complicate
complexity you for large application but
never mind actually just for a simple
one just need to prototype like this
just give things out put them statically
like text in here so you can easily
visualize them and you know design your
interface first then add the
functionality to it so jumping in here
since we're gonna work on the top corner
of it I'm just gonna put it that I'm
gonna go to inside of the SRC create
another folder I'm gonna name is folder
line component so it's gonna hold all
the components just the best practice
actually for me when it comes to reiax
applications is to put your side
components you're like you know small
components into a different folder
called components then you can actually
call them from a main application
components I'm gonna create the first
one it's gonna be top dots GSX so I'm
gonna create another one it's going to
be the bottom
JSX so you can actually name them
whatever but just you know naming like
this would be pretty good I'm gonna pour
first we asked from the yaks we always
do so and I'm gonna just export defaults
a normal components stay [ __ ] phone
election you're not gonna work with the
status components in this case I'm gonna
say top okay top section it seemed like
this is a little bit much we're gonna
react the components and it's gonna have
a constructor as all of them does and
take the props and actually we can we
can call super props and you can have a
state in the stem and empty objects of
states and just a render function or you
simply and this return render function
what it does it just like returns
another container you can actually use
no can use it like a div in this case
you put something like this inside of it
just for quick visualization you can
copy a little things in here and put it
in the bottom without your problem just
changing this to bottom section and
going here changing it and there we go
just you know you've got two separate
files two separate sections for you
ready to go now jump me back into the up
dog chance and here we actually we can
import our sections so I'm gonna do
imports top section and from the
components folder I'm gonna go inside
components you grab the top and there we
go so I'm just gonna go in at winter
this section is out of here okay there
we go
it does have no props actually so we can
easily just render it simply just by
calling it can fold it like this and it
should be much work isn't clear right
here now we can just move with the
developments into the top dog genius X
instead of putting air all the code
yourself about genius because it's way
way much better for you know a civil
application so you can disappear it with
our your team people can actually read
it in this generational happening behind
the scenes well then just put in all the
chunk of your code logic and application
logic
the you are in you know just mix them
all together you son of a father's gonna
be really really painful for a lot of
people actually who's gonna read your
coke so make sure to do so if the rights
wait here if you take a look on the
prototype boy he wants is the first to
get the title up and the times actually
gotta be centered right over here so
we're gonna use the display flex and
let's go ahead and get this out of the
way so I'm just gonna create a class in
here cost name I'm gonna need this for
example I don't know let's try to top
container okay that seems quite decent
instead of a top container we're gonna
have and I'm gonna have the top title
and we're gonna have actually another
stateless components we're just gonna
create it down here just in a second so
I'm gonna have this is actually the
title I'm gonna say they've da title
just gonna need me like this for the
class name and here I'm gonna say this
is gonna be actually the brother oh I
just try to name the application
actually whether up instead of like
whether it up like this and it actually
means the weather up always so always
actually get your weather or something
you can choose another meaningful name
for the application of course I'm not
that much of person who actually does
the name you know selection or something
this I'm not good at ice at all so yeah
hopefully you can just go ahead and
figure out a better name for this and
let me know why not so it's gonna be the
weather application jumping into the
style let me just move this into
alongside the top adjacent there here
we're gonna have so the title but it's
out of the top section and we're gonna
have actually this this actual container
so it's gonna be the top container or we
can easily just move it right over here
so it's not gonna be having any any any
bad [ __ ] but the best thing is not to
mix the up dot CSS or the are the main
CSS Styles all of them just put them in
one single found it's gonna be really
painful as well so you meet for each
component to split the sass or the split
the style for them and put each style on
a separate file for each component and
when I talk when for an
cojones is actually when you have big
components like components that plays
major roles on the development of
glycation when it comes to a component
for example to a button is actually if
you gonna reuse this button it across
the whole pages of your application a
lot of code other components gonna
depend on this body
you obviously gonna go ahead and do the
sound for them separately in a separate
style sheet file so it's gonna be way
much better for your shitty guys you're
gonna put here another one which is
gonna be the top style or the best way
actually to go with this one is let me
just gonna show you this I'm gonna
create another folder I'm gonna name
this stop I'm gonna create another one
gonna name it bottom so we can just copy
this and put this at the top it says
move okay and any actually videos to
your code likely tells you to or
notifies you if you want to update the
imports to for the mood files I'm gonna
say yes okay I'm gonna take the bottom
as well and move it in here and it's
gonna ask us again so hopefully it does
is actually asking I don't know
something is actually wrong with this
anyway so I'm just gonna rename this
into indexed of Junius and why don't we
need here is just kind of like whenever
we try to access the top top just only
the top directory near the top folder it
automatically knows that we want the
entity s if you specify another file
name obviously just gonna go ahead and
enforce the file name for you
simple enough I'm gonna change this as
well in here I'm just gonna put it in
Dixie s so now we have like this is the
bottom this is the main entry point of
it and we can put some style files in
him she's gonna put like style dots and
CSS for this and I'm gonna create
another one in here so it's gonna be
style to add CSS pretty great
here we're gonna have the style for the
actual top file so let me just move this
into it so actually in the top so we're
gonna have the top container and it'd be
the main container inside of it we have
a title and the top containers upset
it's gonna be a display flex so it's
gonna have like a flex display
and flex direction is gonna be a column
so columns actually just you know like
to display them vertically in here so
yes surface horizontally if you want
horizontally you can use the well we set
up a column you can use also reverse row
reverse call them and stuff like this
you're gonna put for example let me just
set the font family for this one so you
can easily change it later on you're
gonna say family you're gonna use the
oxygen if it is actually defined for
your browser or something I'm gonna use
as well so serif is stead of its in case
is not defined we will just you know
fall back and into the sauce serve fun
so I'm gonna set a font size so the font
size is gonna be about 22 pixels because
it's kind of a title so we wanted to
show up and going in here and we're
gonna have like a color for it so the
call was gonna be ffff for completely
whites and yeah so this is this is
basically what we want to hear we need
to Center it since we want this into the
actual center so we probably what we
want is all the other components
actually you want them into the center
so we can just take this and put it
right over those so we will think more
about this select location we can have
this fun and let me just move this so we
can have this button moved out since
you're right here we don't have to do
anything with all those spaces in there
yeah we can we can have that but it
depends on you and how you want to lay
out or style and structure your
application so I'm just gonna do okay
just if I can't is I'm gonna Center it
this is actually really using a column
so this probably should pretty much work
and make sure to include the style file
in here so we could recognize this
really easily so we can just go ahead
and do style.css now it tells us that it
couldn't open up anything in here so you
just don't back into the Alto JSX and
actually you couldn't find out or
something
so yeah it's pretty bad from
there we go just probably friends to the
index when you actually go ahead and
exit the the actual running watch or the
server development just you know control
see and you can remove this index and
you can just go ahead and rerun that's
because it has a also another bar guy
found out about that it actually doesn't
recognize the index whenever you try to
rename the files once it's actually
running or something like this so just
you know get her your head over it try
to fix it or something this now he works
without any problems hopefully we can
jump back into the reacts application
yeah he shows actually nothing for the
top container or something is it does
shows nothing because we have you
haven't set any background yes so we're
just gonna try to grab this background
this really nice dark blue background
and try to put it right over there so
I'm gonna go to the side up top I'm
gonna say background color okay I'm
gonna just space the color and hopefully
now he shows but the height is actually
not taking the full space I'm just going
to say height 100% as well as the width
so now there we go so just control s
there we go we've got we've got now the
weather app actually 22 pixels - quite a
lot so I'm just going to move it to 20
and it's actually a Centurion I don't
want the just in my contents yeah this
we are using the column so we need to
use the align items okay now we should
pretty much work there we go we've got
the weather up perfectly Center it up
there and we everything pretty much
working fine without any problems or
issues or something and everything is
actually working as expected
now we can have another components that
is going to be placed right down here
which is gonna play the role of
displaying all the data that is about
this so all of this data is actually
gonna be grabbed from the API hook so
whenever we call the API and ap I'm
gonna use this at 8 I don't know API Xu
or something this calm it's pretty good
it gives you really nice in your free
trial about about 10
hits a month or something this so we can
use this intestine in career application
probably you're not gonna reach out ten
thousands a month you could have another
api's services that provide ApS like
this for free you might find another
better one you know you can just go
ahead and just update the application
like this and that would be really nice
for you so I was upset it's gonna be all
of it just the containing components
that we can create another component
separately for it and it's gonna be
well another with stateful components
for this one so I'm just gonna do class
it's out of this we can actually have
any solder vest or we can create it
separately different file the best way
is actually to create a separate file
because you know you can take it as each
file takes one single components unless
a file has a stateful component and a
status components when it comes to
status components it doesn't actually
count as a real component you got a
point pretty much so here we can create
um I don't know so we can we can call
this like whether don't care sex or
something okay
that seems quite interesting there we
can in this regards from reacts and it
can explore defaults I could put a class
name it weather okay the next ends we
are stock components it's gonna have a
constructor in everything and why I'm
adding a stateful component instead of
the safest components because we're
gonna have a stay it's gonna be managed
by this since we need an API call we
need to hit the server and give the deal
and fetch it from from the actual API at
the rest of I so we need to change the
stage like over time you need to set the
stage whether we set it to normal since
we have a receiver there's any errors or
something and we set the actual state
update the actual current Celsius coming
the whether we update the image and
stuff like this so we're gonna see more
about this when it comes to real word
things when it comes to working with the
or dealing pretty much with a restful
api and here I'm gonna have the render
so just gonna be basically ranking a
very basic scaffold they think here what
we have is actually a container so I'm
gonna return a div dodds
weather container okay and for this
weather container we're gonna have is
actually the first is the location name
then these two containers one is holding
the image the other one is actually
holding the currents I don't know the
current weather and just we have another
container down here which is gonna be
sunny or shows the the currents weather
details so sunny or cloudy or whatever
things actually happening so we have in
here it's gonna be the way the container
it's gonna be flex designed or the flex
box you think about this second so we
can have the best I'm gonna create a div
so basically you can have another
container inside of this I'm just gonna
name this inner container so we can
style them the best way and this
container we're gonna have what above
this header and footer so you can
actually solid us this way
and inside of this we can have two
containers like image or now we can just
call this image another one we can we
can call this actually current weather
okay there you go you just put like 10
and the ridge here location name so we
can actually test with them and we can
see what's going on you can put for
example sunny and there we go now okay
the next step is to take this components
I'm actually calling the top in here so
we can actually right before right
pretty much right after the weather up
title we need to render this components
and get everything as I've said I just
want to put all static information in
here that's why I added all this
in here but later on we can use the
weather API to get all of the dynamic
data on our components so just simply
import that in here so let me just go
ahead and do that really quick and then
I'm gonna say this is gonna be weather
components and we departed from the the
final components that we have just
created symbols that and now we just
need to like render it right down here
so in the city weather and there we go
so our control let's save that and going
back into the reactor application is
just gonna use the hot reload or to
reload for you guys in here and then we
go you've got location name image here
and 10 degrees in here and and then
basically says it's sunny or something
like this so it's not quite as we
expected it to be but it does actually a
great job so we try now to add some
stylings the way you actually love to
add style is to my evil rack reacts
applications or any other CSS style
whether you're creating a normal static
website HTML CSS website or you're
dealing with a reacts application or any
other framework here using it doesn't
actually matter because at the end you
are going to deal with in with the CSS
so you need like a live preview of your
CSS you can actually just go back in
here type in the CSS save and let the
he'll hold reload or you can go back and
refresh that it's gonna take a quite
some time for your actually guys to
develop the application to see the
actual size and since actually designers
or who designs web page and what
developers actually takes a lot of time
to put a web page together they need to
do a lot of modification a lot of
resizing things a lot of putting things
in your color changing font families and
font sizes of all different things that
makes you feel really uncomfortable
while trying to do this so the best way
is actually throughout the dev tools
usually dev tools the power of the dev
tools and put some CSS Styles from here
so we can heal it really really help you
watch through what with your journey as
a web developer and put in CSS Styles
together so now I'm gonna probably do
just go into the weather app or the
weather container in here so clear
receipts it's completely empty it
doesn't have any style just gonna start
with a display and gonna put a flex
display I'm gonna change the Flex
direction to column so I want them like
you know like you know just in a column
laying here but it's basically a little
bit more calm
located in NASA since we have in here
this is the hater and we have like two
components then we have the future so
this is actually we're gonna have like
three or one more container so this
represent the header the other one
represents an inner container and the
last one here the sunny thing represents
the future so I've got go ahead and work
around with this because this way is not
gonna work so we need to work around the
structure and changed a little bit since
you have a delay here let's quickly see
the inner container the footer and the
header we already did the structure and
everything so we need to structure it
using the CSS file and put it actually
together in order to actually you know
make difference so this now we just put
it like a display flex in years it's a
flux container and everything now we
need to go into the hitter and I'm gonna
say this is also gonna be a display flex
flex tie Russian is gonna be low so it's
always gonna take the row thing in here
yeah it's basically that it is I'm gonna
go to the inner container and we add
another display flex just gonna say flex
but this time the Flex die rush is gonna
be well as well because we want them to
be displayed as well like the image is
gonna be alongside the degrees or the
Celsius of the weather so basically they
said the image on the right image of the
on the left side and we've got the
degrees in here on the right side
basically this is basically what we want
and finally we've got the footer so it's
just simply as we did in the other side
so I'm just gonna display flex and I can
I can just like put flex or justified
content to Center this out because I
needed in center as well as at the
location name I need this in center so
we can just go back to the header and do
justified content to Center it's already
being centered because the width thing
is taking the full of it but you can you
can see actually the difference when
once the science is actually or the text
is getting smaller so yeah it doesn't
actually matter for this time now we can
just jump back in here we can go to the
style of the weather and that if I added
a style anyway so I've add like I have
top style I can add or create another
style file but that doesn't really
matter because it's not really that big
of an applet
Asian that much of large or something so
I can simply just go ahead and try to
put a header in here or try to create
another container since it's inside the
weather container in here so I'm just
gonna add a class I'm gonna say weather
container simply and I'm gonna add dots
okay
you can't go outside I still can't find
the time I'm gonna have the heater add
this kind of things into it I'm going to
add the inner container and I'm gonna
add the future
finally so when you just don't back call
people all things it's just basically a
bunch of display flex and stuff like
this it's not really that much of a big
deal and I've got here the same thing
for the future basically so just go
ahead and copy that's just just like
Center is the text and you can put that
there
now I should say that it should be much
take effects immediately without any
problems and okay we see it works with
all your problems the one thing it just
needs to add in here is just like
justify contact to Center save that it
should actually take the center
perfectly without any problems so yeah
hopefully now it works so anyway let us
jump into now trying to add a little bit
of better style to it because it looks
so really really ugly so in the header
or the whole container I'm just going to
change the color of the funds to white
because we are having a dark background
so it's better to change it to a lighter
color this is actually the best way all
the best practice you can take it as a
web designer and well this is the color
here we've got the location name and
when want is like just to get some a
little bit of margin from the top from
the actual tight so I don't want just
all of them are stuck together in here
at the top so instead of that was gonna
say marching the stop I'm just gonna say
I don't know about 3:00 a.m. or
something that's quite a lot let's add
one okay that seems nothing's thesis or
one point you okay that sounds good you
can just copy that as well I always love
to
many things because saving changes are
really important because it just refresh
the page or you do some ugly mistake or
stupid thing and and all of your CSS
styles in here are God so make sure just
go ahead and save them before you do a
stupid mistake or something this we've
got the location name now the location
name the image and all the degrees we've
gotten now to go ahead and just grab the
image and just display over there and
they need to just take the font size a
little bit down because this is looking
ugly I don't want it to look like me
list so just font size let me just put
it for example 18 pixels that's quite a
large you're gonna put location in
simply this 13 pixels and I'm gonna put
for the inner container I'm gonna put
some well let's just leave it like this
for the inner continue I'm gonna put the
down or the future just or on this touch
sighs I'm gonna put its a thing 13
pixels will do the job perfectly and
there we go so we can just put that here
so okay
styling key quantity sometimes so yeah
it's probably gonna take the hobble
video that's why you see me actually
give it a lot of it and since I haven't
created this my project anyway it's the
first time creating it with you like a
rough life thing from scratch so I have
no idea actually how it looks like or
something like this and you actually can
have some I don't know examples of how a
developer actually works and how you can
how you can you know take some tips
techniques and how you can absorb things
and you know use them for your side and
help you guys into the other side I
completely think
forget about taking something in here
which is the margins up I think yeah I
just okay let me just stop take this
really quick I can't close it off so let
us see you might point you yeah I'm
gonna put the color to whites
you're gonna use hex in here because
it's way much better I can get rid of
that anyway in here
doesn't really matter so we can refresh
but still there's nothing actually
taking effect or something
yeah missing a missing it ended here so
it's not quite as I expected to be
whether continue you can save that and
there we go so location name Sonny butts
is seeking the margin from here while I
shouldn't have put it there okay good
pretty nice actually so I can put some
margin as well margin top and margin
bottom I can puts about and eight pixels
or something or let's say ten pixels is
quite good and we could put zero pixels
from the left in the right and yeah it
looks pretty decent let me just try to
go ahead and grab this image I've
already started off this image in my
desktop I have just a messy desktop in
here a lot of things are just going on I
can just copy these things I copy this
both of these images which is gonna be
used for the bottom and it's just like
two shows the Sun just for now just for
the static thing because later on out of
the API it's gonna completely change the
look and feel of it so yeah it's
basically just for now okay let's try
now to take a look for this kind of
things hopefully it should work pretty
much the same so I need to go let me see
Assoc school clear see they put it a
logo inside of here so we can clear it
do to the SRC reveal and Explorer and
try to put something in there I'm just
gonna put it in your folder name their
resources inside of resources I'm gonna
put some like images or something you
can name whatever folder you like but
I'm just gonna use this quite good name
I've got some PNG and sunny weather JPEG
this is Ryan need so just refreshing
that to make Visual Studio code a word
about the new folder has been created in
the directory and working directory and
now we can just go ahead and import it
and since we need to import inside of
weather components so I'm gonna do that
really quick in there and actually
create react up that's over handling
behind the scenes of images and stuff so
you don't really have to care about how
what pack does the bundling thing or how
how you actually can import an image
using webpack Pierre we axe app has the
configuration already so you don't
really have to
think about it just go ahead and
implement it okay now we can grab that
really quick I'm just gonna import it as
a normal components you can deal with
images as a normal component so I'm just
gonna go back since if you are inside
we're inside the top so we can grab Sun
image from they'll be back once okay so
I go back we go to resources images and
we grab the sound of PNG
now we can create an image container
here is its image here we're gonna
create an image with an S or C holding
up this so it's gonna be here some image
I'm just gonna get rid of this I can put
down sand zeroes actually gonna go so go
here and there we go we've got the Sun
but it's not quite centered and
everything but I need you to go ahead
and try to add a little bit of style I'm
gonna put it with how to presents hi -
hi / % it takes the the Paris container
this is basically what I want to do so
takes the parent container with and now
we can put the width the custom width to
this one so for example kind of puts I
don't know when I am here she's not what
it once good hi it's three or something
that's quite a lot okay seems seems
quite good well you know it's not really
that much of a clears everything well it
looks pretty good every way so yeah I
don't know but okay let's try to copy
that you know going to the style it's
out of the inner container since all of
them are inside of the inner container
cook which image can put some work
inside of it and inside of that we have
an image tag or image element so you can
reference that too and that's why I love
actually using sass or less and just
like a CSS preprocessor because it helps
you a lot to nest and tubular missed
tags inside all those tags nested
classes instead of IDs and containers or
children inside of its container so
someone so forth so it really really
helps out during the development of
things like this applications so we can
gofer image and it can put the with
hundred percent and it could put high as
well so okay
hundred percents there we go
so should do the job perfectly but it's
not perfectly centered as we thought it
would
now we need to fix it in some styling
way so we have the image and we have the
actual weather they shouldn't actually
take the full height or something I'm
just gonna take tele2 for the contents
and there we go and I'm just gonna eat
you as the display flex so is that I'm
gonna use flex display to justify it it
now vertically instead of horizontally
I'm just gonna say line items Center
there we go
now it does do it perfectly I just need
to take the font size a little bit up
for this one
but everything is actually working
pretty much fine without any problems
this class is actually named currents
rather and it's not it's not much for
this man for this one and this one is
actually hard to fits the contents
basically yeah and I'm gonna take the
font size a little bit so it could be a
little bit more obvious 20 pixels is
that a good job or it's not so looking
to a three or even more than that to
your phone okay because this is the main
thing you want to show up yeah it's
really important to show up up in a
really big font size because it really
really matters I mean just gonna try to
just copy this one yeah just gonna take
it and it's out of the weather in here
just gonna put it right there and just
copy paste in it so now we can look a
little bit much better like we will
still see us think and if we take a look
it looks pretty much identical to this
one not a big difference you just need
to automate this and it takes the height
a little bit of that and take this
actually down a little bit so just go
and try to fix this same styles of gods
is that
just use a selection the inspection here
it's actually a header or it's basically
knots okay is that I'm just grab this
real quick it is inside of the time so
when it can take you down this and it
compared some emoji to the top of five
pixels that quite good okay pretty good
nice can take this can go to the style
basically you think yep just now it
looks pretty good there we go now what
we need is actually we have we have done
this kind of things in here with bit of
the Sun with whether that's we just need
the bottom in here which is the select
location button that shows us some
custom location that we can select and
manipulate and actually we can select
this location later on so we can
actually probably just show up some kind
of a pop-up whenever we click this
button it will show a pop-up we tell the
user to enter the name inside of like an
input tell the user to enter the name of
the location he wants to get the
information of the weather from then
afterwards we're gonna use the API that
I showed you and we can we can actually
send the request we grab the deal about
this particular steady or tickle those
zip code and we get this data and
actually we discipline it to him like
the weather and we tell him whether it's
actually a sunny or whatever other image
in here we can automate this kind of
things because this API that I'm just I
told you about the API xu thing that
allows you to actually get the weather
it also provides you with images of
real-time weather so whether you're
actually getting sun it shows you an
image of shot or it gives you in the
callback in the response an image of sun
or actually it gives you an image of
nights like a dark moon or something
like this so it's pretty identical
pretty good for us actually other
developers so you don't really have to
do a lot of things I just like automates
a lot of you a lot of things behind the
scenes for you so you can care less
about images and automation like this
and yeah so we've got to go ahead and
add a Potter in here and actually inside
of the top so because did I do
let's name this opponent I'm gonna take
last name of a BTN VTN can select
location okay we have now you can just
go have some kind of a style class in
here like a comedy class we're just
gonna name it BTN well that would be
better if we put it the side of the up
dot CSS so it'd be available for
everything it's gonna name this but BTW
and in here and yeah i like inputs start
up here I can put some customization for
this particular class like the busy and
select vocation class which can be
actually used for any other thing but
it's particularly may flow location so
we can just go ahead and put it inside
of I don't know so we can we can put it
just like the top container and you
should be there or just like leave it
alone here okay pretty good no problems
actually the sign of this button what
we're gonna do let me just try to put a
bottom first then we can care about how
we can style it or something there we go
just put the name or the title of the
button and yeah it doesn't actually look
as we want it to be but it will
so with this really nice color we'll try
to make it with with some borders and
broader radius and stuff so it's gonna
first I'm gonna put it's gonna change
the bulb is just solid and put some kind
of a a a coloring on there or just try
to put two to two
okay that's that's not good DDD okay
seems good we can go now to let me just
put some margin around it like the
margin from the top of the left
so I can put 15 pixels it looks pretty
decent now 0 from the left to the right
and you can jump in here you grab a
collar and we just like this really
quick though the Texas pop this one copy
the hexadecimal value the background and
it can pull the background color really
easily
there we go kind of identical you can
change the font size to 16 pixels size
quite large you know seems seems decent
to me or we can take it down a little
bit much further I don't know what font
size is actually using but is actually
let me select the text it's using
rowboat so I don't think if it's that
available for us spots I try so ponds
family I think so that is actually
available it's not just gonna fall back
to the same serve so you can easily use
that and I can add some bold already
quite a lots now a actually seems good
okay two pixels is pretty decent and
okay that that's actually pretty good
and it can change the color a little bit
you make it a dark grey so it can put a
a8 around there or much better thing 5x5
there we go there's like while II want
it to be but okay that's that's pretty
decent I try to copy into this one I'm
gonna fall just take them this a bottle
I'm gonna take the margin and this and
we can just left the old all of the
other ones too customizable things so we
can copy that it can put inside of the
bottom in here and they can both have
merged together without any problems and
yeah that is actually working pretty
much fine I can just go ahead and remove
the outline from from the bottom here
I'm gonna say this and I'll yeah I'm
gonna kind of change the focus okay that
should work if we try to press dance or
something we'll try to focus the bunny
in general you're not actually gonna get
any outline or something that's that's
pretty decent so it works as we expect
it to be now we actually need to work a
little bit on the bottom side in here so
go into bottom and the index dot G is
for the bottom in here and we have just
do a couple of things I show you for it
let's first just try to add the class
name so I'm gonna do bottom container
it's just gonna be the container and
inside of this container if you can
clearly look how is that so if you clear
look at here
I'm gonna just use this image in here
from from this prototype so I'm just
gonna put this image in the background
that just before you got this image into
my source code just put it there and
we're probably you probably not so we
can just go ahead and layer on how to
forecast for the couple of next days we
just just do a very simple forecast
because working on it's gonna take more
much much more time it's not that much
of complicated since you know the
principles and actually the basics of
getting restful api is done in here and
just one single components which we're
gonna work one in a couple of minutes of
course and getting everything done in
here it's gonna be just free simple just
playing around with react and when doing
single one a couple of times actually
using a group and we're doing a
components a couple of times actually
just showing the forecast for every
single day and you're done so this is
pretty much it
no not much of complicated or anything
else so as I've said let's go and jump
into my source code and you have already
put the image inside of as we've seen
just the sunny weather so it's a lovely
image you can find may work much better
image of course but I'll just go and
stick with this for now I'm just going
to go to the style of the bottom and
to add to this so I'm just gonna do
ballroom - container so we're gonna add
it a couple of styles we're gonna do a
background - color to it and or just
like the background and we can we can
basically put a URL for this background
which gonna be we have the stylist out
of this so we need to get out of this
and is inside of components so we need
to get out to two times we're just gonna
go back once and go back twice and we
can go inside of resources then regard
images Sonny Boy little JPEG and it
pretty much should do the job perfectly
without any problems we might do some
linear gradients about that but there's
still not really not much of fun think
of it just try to put the width so it's
gonna be a hundred percent hey that's
not really where one's height as well is
gonna be a hundred percent and yeah
there we go try to save that also make
sure to go ahead and and for this I'm
not important in these style sheets so
you're gonna do style dots a CSS which
is referencing a relative path of it
just saving this you should go job now
can Joe go back in here I think we're
not seeing any changes anyway so let me
just see this the bottom container is is
this actually imaginary or yep it is but
seems a little bit off okay let's check
it's the bottom a class of it's a top
section in the bottom section
okay I'm not not even importing this
either so yeah go into the app dodgiest
and you need to import the top section
you didn't do even mess I'm just gonna
do bottom section from components
forward slash bottom and four slash
index so I'm gonna grab the index from
there and down most cases in heroes can
clearly see I'm putting the index I
don't know for some reason it's giving
me an error because most of cases like
99
percent of times you're not required to
put the index in here because no GIS or
on your compiler is actually webpack in
most cases it knows about that it's
smart enough to know that you are
watching the index since you only
reference it the actual path in here in
the actual folder only we're not putting
a name of a file inside of it it always
gonna go ahead and look off for a file
name by default I named index dot
something dot jstor doctype script or
something like this by this case we are
required to put it for some reason right
now it's just like a really bad buck so
it's really annoying you know here I'm
gonna put the same thing I'm just gonna
put court on section and there we go so
just simple sighs we can now we can jump
back in here hopefully we wait for it to
compiler and I'm taking quite some time
and yeah there we go
we've got a really ridiculous not
censored image or something anyway so I
need to work on this image a little bit
so it can keep with the center or I can
always try to figure out something okay
so all these centers actually working
for this kind of not really why once but
yeah it's it's a little bit annoying
because the image is not fitting the
right spot in here so yeah I want to
just like to resize the whole thing in
here and it takes the full width in the
full height of it so I'm gonna add the
property off background noise so so this
property basically it lets you size the
background on image of brown where I'm
actually on a container however your
city wants as a cover as accounting
basically we want them to cover so it
can actually scale and fits the inner
width and the height of the container so
this is what basically what we want and
you never can put the center and it can
put on free sample no repeats so it
doesn't actually repeat or something
just to make sure that you won't repeat
it anyway and there we go if not
everything basically working as expected
but still not looking as we want it to
be in here at the preview it's a little
bit deemed to screen clearest in here so
we've got some
linear color about this and this is
actually the CSS code of this linear
color I'm just gonna copy I'm just gonna
show you what is what does this linear
color does so the linear color you can
change it a little bit to look a little
bit much better for us which I am doing
it now to make here look a bit better
and yeah other than that's just looking
a little bit off so I tried to look good
okay this this seems decent she's gonna
go and copy the code and this is the
nicest things about figma it lets you
copy the CSS code right out of the box
so just you don't really need to go
ahead and through it from the beginning
and takes all the stuff and all things
around so just like to bring your
ingredients you add advanced you tell
like which degrees and you give it the
hexadecimal color and from where she
goes like from top to left or right to
left and some one and so forth you cast
like basic direction in and there we go
so you can have this just before we
specify the URL and we can add down a
comma and there we go it's just doing it
basically as as we want it to be now
pretty good you can even actually find a
little bit better and smoother linear
gradient color in here and much much
better image in here to put in the
background just you know if you do that
make sure just go put in Pula course or
something that's just let me see you
preview your application your version of
your application so we can I don't know
see what you can actually do it and how
productive you are so let's try not to
basically copy this and go back in here
go to the CSS style and roselucia so let
me just copy it just nearby this so we
can work flawlessly and I'm just gonna
paste this one very simple save it and
you should pretty much work fine it's
okay we see in here nothing has been
changed or something let me just get rid
of that text it's really annoying I
don't want any text or something I'm
just gonna keep it smooth the nice and
empty for now so everything would look
calm basically the ones are however you
actually want it to be so looking pretty
basic with all your problems and stuff
and now it's time okay for working with
the actual API now what we need is to
get the real dynamic data here all of
those all these like Sony tags then the
vocation name
and this is Imogen here all of them
actually are stunning and since we were
creating a real word weather application
we don't really want to deal with any
static things in here want everything to
be dynamic so we can just go ahead and
put a request there and you know fetch
some data from a specific API and we get
the JSON data from from this for the
forecast for like of the current weather
for today's weather basically and for
the forecast for example for the next
ten days or something like this you can
specify how many days you can guess and
there's a limit for that of course but
the API we're gonna use is actually
called API Xu it's it's a really awesome
weather API and the reason you choose
this over the others because it gives
you like a 10,000 hits per month for
free and since we just want them for
testing purposes it's not really for
commercial things or something like this
so it's definitely worth it and you can
just cover any trynna it's super simple
it gives you a really meaningful data
that you can use so just go ahead
register that's dislike the website so
just go API Xu comm you can just go and
create your accounts basically you need
the key phrase let me just go in and
just give you a quick overview of this
API so this like an interactive API
Explorer that lets you test the API and
see what does the API actually have and
what they are at does it would care for
you what does it provide and does it you
feel much neater or not it gives you two
options if XML JSON of course we're
gonna use JSON because XML is just like
hell and since we're using javascript
JSON is like the feature for JavaScript
basically you want now nowadays to use
JSON for everything so I know so we want
to use HTTP over HTTP for a secure layer
and here you just put the value for the
query which is basically the city name
that you want to get the forecast for
it's like he needs to use the city name
you can use country or something because
a city name is what basically describes
a weather forecast and here you can
choose acreage weather a forecast
weather like search also complain and
history whether that's like you know
already or the history of the weather
the past these past years or something
that's not really much interesting once
we want a real-time weather application
so we can get the forecast weather or
the current weather let's just kind of
try to work with a forecast weather
because later on we might and as I've
told you the forecast with a couple of
next days so we can just go end up with
the forecast for the weather for the
next days basically so we want to use
the forecast weather instead of
occurrence rather here we put the query
so which city I'm gonna just put London
just use it as example you can put how
many days you want against is like up to
ten days of a forecast I'm just
basically gonna put for example five
it's quite decent and you can just go
and show the response make sure to put
your API key in here in order to be able
to test that and it gives you this
really awesome JSON structured data in
here really really easy with with a
really important and crucial information
that we need throughout application it
gives you the name of the city it gives
you the region specifically gives you
for example the latitude longitude which
you might not need it for this
application but you definitely need it
for all the things that gives you an ID
so where exactly is like inside of
Europe and London so a local time and a
local time is like what is the current
time of getting this weather Deana so
you can you can do a plenty of things
for this there's also occurrence objects
in here so like the last updated the
last update as well a bargain is just
like the milliseconds or it's a
timestamp a temporary in so sheís or
temporary infer and so I'm gonna
basically used Celsius in this case like
four degrees is they so it's like a
boolean tells you if this city is
currently hot today or at night it's
basically when it tells you 0 so you can
take it as a boolean either 0 or 1 so it
basically outlines the condition of this
is clear and it gives you the icon and
the I kind of forking about is basically
the icon as we have used in here so it's
like the Sun icon it gives you a Sun
icon or it gives you something like calm
night icon like a moon Half Moon I can't
clearly see in here
so Half Moon icon you can clearly go
ahead and use this because as I told you
we're gonna make everything image the
text and the location name and the sunny
text in here
everything's gonna be dynamic so we're
gonna use this weather API my really
really awesome and a couple more all the
things and also we've got an important
thing like the forecast and it gives you
an array of forecast days signing off
from the first day so I was starting
from zero this is the first day
temperature and the condition and
everything all information and you've
got basically all the data that you need
for the days that you've specified like
the up the next up days or five days and
there we go so you simply just go ahead
and try and need to install Axios
so just do NPM install Axios it makes
you to save it as a dependency so what
basically acts EOC is just like a
library that allows you to send and
receive HTTP request is and receive
pretty much responses very easily with
an awesome API and it uses promises this
is the best part
since it uses promises it gets you out
of the old way and it promises a great
way to deal with async code and all the
callback hell think so promises are the
the thing that you should actually take
care more about especially now nowadays
you should use promises no callbacks are
required and for HTTP request is
actually is doing pretty great job with
a lot of features and stuff so you
should probably just go ahead and do it
already take install that make sure to
stall it is really minimal not read that
much of big deal you can just go and
jump the that's and now we need to get
the actual API key in here so you can
just go in and grab this API key copy it
and we can go and use it but for now
they're just gonna see how we can work
with application so remember that we've
got the top section and the bottom
section and both of them are wanting to
access the weather API Deana so how we
can do this for example some of your my
tasks or my seed like like a proposition
they say like upto n inside of at the
top components in here like the top
section and do a request like you send
an HTTP request and receive the DRAM
then you actually go ahead and render
this particular the uninstall of the
render method
free basic huh so this is not the case
actually what about the bottom section
in here so the weather section and the
bottom section are completely separate
siblings they have nothing to do with
each other and then they don't actually
know each
so they can't exchange the DN unless we
use some kind of a phlox or something
that we were using but it's not the
practical thing to do because you're
gonna hit or request the server twice
and since you've got a plan that you're
not needed to request this particular
server because you have got a limits
like ten thousand hits per month or
something and you're actually doing it
wrong because you're gonna request it
over the top component or the top
section then you're gonna move on to the
bottom section and do another request
which is absolutely nonsense you
shouldn't actually do this so you only
need to go ahead and hit the server only
once while you once your application is
actually starting because your
application is basically about weather
up DN a so you need to do it on the
startup of the application then passing
this DN a-- as prompts to both of the
components and remember that we've got
the application here which is the main
render of both of these sections like he
renders the top section and it renders
the bottom section so we should actually
fetch the DNS all of the up dog chains
then we take this the other three have
gone pass it through down through to the
top section in the bottom section they
can actually use it throughout the
prompts pretty basic now for fetching
any data for using restful api as with
react the best way to go through or the
best way to set up your request and
receive the response and handle all the
data you get is inside of the components
in mount method so it's actually the
best method that you should choose for
send a request there's all our methods
are here but this is the one because
once your components actually just
mounted you you've got access to all of
the inner data and in references of your
crew motion components and you're not
gonna get any errors or something like
when you put this inside of component
did update or something like state
conflicts or something like this
everything's gonna work for your print
for you and this is the best phase to
push the the data now we've gotta access
some kind of account so I'm just gonna
set up we were seeing here the ideas up
constructor I think behind the scenes so
it's simple just go ahead and setup a
constructor as a normal constructor I
didn't show that I think of the video
boss yeah
just set up a constructor mean you put
the stage
pretty basically in here what we're
gonna do is just gonna put a couple of
things I'm just gonna say well let me
clean a Const variable that's gonna be
accessed from here I'm gonna say whether
key equals I'm gonna take my key and put
it in here so okay I've got I've got a
key let me just copy dance and make sure
to get your key so you can put any
handset counts because not gonna change
anyway so we can give any use dance and
I'm gonna just set up a couple of things
since we need this city name so we're
gonna see the name also we need back to
the days of a forecast I'm gonna need
your check for we're gonna have a place
to stay they're gonna say City I'm gonna
be something London okay and I'm gonna
and forecast please it's gonna be five
days okay that's pretty good you can use
up to 10 days in here I'm gonna just go
in and use the D structure of the states
so we can fetch the data out of those
states very easily without any headache
we're gonna say is to name and the
forecast days this both states okay now
we need some ah here this is the weather
API and everything now we need to use
Axios to hit this data so obviously just
go ahead and like and pull that very
easy just doing poor Axios from Axios
and there we go you've got ax use
available for uranium you can go ahead
and use it let's totally before Axios
uses a promise based API so it's very
easy for you to go through it I'm gonna
do a get request since this accepts a
good request to this particular API or
this particular you want to I'm gonna
just do it here and before doing any
request is we need to set up the URL
first I'm gonna just copy the round
we're gonna put it between the string
literals because it's gonna allow us to
intraplate some variables it's out of
this and this is a really important we
need to ensure or place some variables
like the API key so we've got it up
there so I'm gonna just go ahead and do
the
whether key and also for the career we
we're gonna roleplay the city name and
also before canadaís that's we've got
there we go so yeah pretty basic now
we've got the URL basically setting up
and everything we can just go and take
and put the URL as I've told you it's
promises so we can use them and catch
and it takes a callback so it takes a
response and we can do anything with
within their response and we can
actually go out and do a catch
so you can catch the error and we can
actually check if the error has anything
to do with that
if it does it gets gonna do consul top
there
okay now fetch weather yeah behind and I
can put the area there so for just very
debugging and we can see clearly what is
going on behind the scenes so we can
just go out and cost about the ear as
well the error objects and if their God
the a response we're gonna do I'm just
gonna do here just console.log with
Athena I'm gonna pretty small so we can
clearly see what is that the end of us
we aren't getting back now we save in
this we go back hopefully in here just
gonna go in and refresh and once the
component is being mounted we're gonna
go ahead and get the data back there we
go we've got that the a successfully no
errors nothing at all and that the other
objects that Axios actually returns for
us has a couple of things it has the
configuration the global comma creation
for for for Axios you can actually set
up and configure we've got the DN a--
which is basically the object that we
receive from the
hitted you are Elvis we just you know
the API that we have just hit and we've
got a couple of haters that has been
sent back from from the service we have
just robbed from the API and basically
the requests that we have just sends
which is the which has a couple of data
actually buts and hitters or stuff and
status and status set like okay or error
or something
depends on what actually states you are
on with this one but basically what we
need is the objects called the error
which has all
the failure scene here we've got the
JSON Deanna she's currents and he comes
to deal all of different things in here
that you can actually access the
different DNA and the forecast and the
location and stuff so we can just go
ahead and use this and what I like in
here using is pipe then inside of then
so this returns an object so you can get
to go ahead and distract this object and
move on to another end which means it's
gonna go and do it like a response
return Deanna and instead of this Dana
I'm gonna need a couple of things I'm
just gonna turn the DNA and the data is
gonna have current forecasts and
location objects I'm just gonna return
this I'm gonna you know point another
then and this is gonna have the actual
dinner so this is the best thing all the
best part about promises so you can
actually point then inside of another
event and so on and so forth that we can
help you a lot throughout your journey
as a web developer in dealing with
asynchronous code in general so the
vending here we've got all the couple of
theater and stuff like this where you
just go ahead update the stage with a
couple of things so since we need the
weather DNF take a look at the top what
we've got we've got just a simple title
the vocation but this one actually needs
a DN a-- so we need something to be
rendered like the degrees and stuff so
let me just go in and set up our prompts
for this the props are we're gonna need
is actually the DN a so i'm gonna access
this let me use a destructor in here I'm
gonna do a cost I'm gonna get the DN a--
out of it because later on I'm gonna
pass the DN a-- throw out to the weather
CSX as a props and then we can go ahead
and give this DN a-- and render it right
over here
so she's gonna say i mean let me see for
the api where is actually naming is
receiving a temporary c to proceed and
week against each day for much
it's like a bully variable shows if it
is they renounce and I don't know we can
guess basically like the condition
although just go and get texts out of
this so the text that we need to display
right over here instead of the sunny and
we can get an icon so I'm just gonna say
icon URL and there we go I'm gonna
subtract this from this side pops and if
you use prop types and react prop types
and stuff like this but it's not really
that much of a big deal in our case so
I'm just gonna return the term cert
Celsius is there I'm gonna replace that
we have the text that we need to show
and the icon and stuff we're gonna I'm
gonna talk more about this in a couple
of seconds but yeah so this is basically
working pretty much fine and yeah this
is what basically what we need let's
just jump back in here for the top and
he it's gonna require something because
it's gonna throw us new you're telling
us we've got no props or something so
and also we needed a location
Observatory for God's gonna say location
I'm gonna gonna put location right over
there so instead of the weather in here
we've got a couple things of
complication because as well a temporary
see okay there's no comma I don't know
this day also got the text and the text
or the icon URL so both of these needs
to be passed as well from from the top
in here so also we need to get them from
the props in you so we can go ahead and
just pass them through this one and
working probably you already did this
way but if you just go ahead and put the
props like use the spread syntax the ESS
president acts to spread the props all
over here just pass it through with
carrying and putting every single prop
name here because they're gonna have the
same prompt names so let me just gonna
copy the whole that's because it's just
like or pretty much cut it go to the
opto Janus X and we've got we need this
on on the top section and I'm gonna give
this from the state because we're gonna
save this in the state I'm gonna do
cause I'm gonna get the city name I'm
gonna get temporary see I'm gonna get
Tuesday I'm gonna get the text and icon
URL so all of those going to be saved
inside of the state so we can go ahead
and access them in here when you just go
in and do this operation so we can do
this set States and we can pass in that
the other that we want the city name is
not gonna be changing or anything
because it's static for now we can deal
of all this they are armed just gonna
put the temporary see it's gonna be deal
out dots let me see this so it's gonna
return the current so we need to access
the currents then we can actually
temporary see so I'm gonna do current
some see also we're gonna need each day
which pretty much instead of the same
thing in here just we need to access the
current started with DN a-- current
copies but it's like a - we're using
comma case and you hear why they using
like - casing in here or something so
yeah this for the east day we can pass
some your water book icon and all the
things of the text so data current
starts
we've gone condition and it's out of
condition we've got text and finally we
can put the icon URL which gonna be da
dark currents edition okay and I'm
simply icon
okay there we go so I know I'm not
getting any pretty fine care with but
it's not really that much it good I've
got a couple of areas that's why it's
not working I need to pass in a couple
of things in here I'm gonna pass the
cname libraries the these day and texts
and finally the icon URL so we can
easily just pipe them through using the
props so we can go ahead and use them
from from the next side and here we just
set this stage without any problems just
simple as that because sending the state
is a really important step to do and I'm
gonna put some kind of a variable in
here so for example I'm gonna put a Leo
teen it's gonna be bullying at first is
you're gonna be true because the
application is gonna start it's gonna be
a Yoda inside of the audience state and
I'm gonna check in here so if there is
actually any loading I'm gonna have a
top section in the bottom section what I
can do
so let me see this I'm only gonna just
go in and do this is how the top section
I'm gonna check let me go out this deal
what do they need this okay Lee odden
let me just add is because always when
naming your bully variables makes them
look and feel as a bullying your
variable like adding it they ease or is
it or or something like makes it like a
boolean variable so like when you ask a
question easily owning so the answer is
pretty much gonna be for example true or
false nothing more nothing less
so this is what I mean by making much
more bullying or thing here so we're
gonna put is Lee odden and so we can
actually render that or not we're
forcing this anyway you can grab it up
there and if it is layout in that's
pretty great if it's not I'm gonna add
another one just
well it's luckily vice-versa it's not
Lee odden we can just go ahead and do
that if it is Lee odden it can remove
the not if it is not reloading what he
can do is render something like weather
okay set some texts I'm gonna put in age
three star Network let me just video
game whether you can make it just a
little bit much better about ideally
odors or any other cool style that make
its gling Z in and smooth a nice button
that will do the job for now does we
want to test the functionality so you
always want to start by testing a
functionality and seeing if your
application logic inner logic actually
works or not so we've got easily Odin
true and here once we finish the early
enough we fetch the data we need to make
this false because it's a really
important step is the you're going to
need to make it to be false so we can
actually end the loop of application
that we tell it is Leo dinner or not we
can save here we can go back in here
what I can do as I've told you the spare
props capabilities I'm just going to put
a dog dog dance this props and we can
bounce this inside of an object in here
and ESX gonna do the job for us with the
lovely people and stuff like this is
gonna help us do that so we can just
gonna spread the syntax because they
have the same names as we have passed in
so we don't really have to do that much
of things that we're gonna give it the
attack finally in here we can just go in
and render it so we can easily go in and
check it for multiplication works Lee
odden weather and I think he never goes
off so we just like keeps the order in
or something I don't know something
ridiculous it's actually really odine
well there we go oh my god it's actually
working and we've got London four
degrees even though there's like there's
no degree sign in here and there's like
the Sun thing we've got clear location
and the text is working pretty much fine
but the icon is not as we want it to be
so we can go and change
and also we can add the degrees thing so
I'm just gonna copy this really quick
from here I mean I mean this section of
the text we can go to the weather and
here we can just um out of this at the
end so it looks much more that we are
using Celsius and it's actual actually a
weather degrees okay in here for the SOC
instead of putting in the Sun image we
can put the icon image and it should
basically work fine but I don't know
let's try this if the weather image
gonna work fine or not and there we go
we've got it that's but it's it's a
little bit notice we expect it to be so
we can jump into the style of this and
you can see this three let me just take
this to form to make it look much better
and there we go it looks much better
much clearer and we've got Valley or
Halfmoon things that's there and it's
selling us for degrees if it you can
take the look on Google and tell him
London weather and yeah he's actually
failing us we got here four degrees I
don't know Google is telling us two
degrees but it's basically the same
thing I think I don't know but yeah our
EPA is actually working we trust in this
API and it working I don't expect me to
get its hundred percents of time fine
but that should do it job perfectly
without any problems I think so
there we go we've got your first API set
up before a weather application that's
pretty good we've got that thing first
now we can take this into the next level
and we can create like the forecasting
is show up the days in here but you
gonna create a couple of seconds
actually you're just gonna do this
really quick and you can also go through
this and select the location so whenever
you select the location you can go ahead
and reload the whole application and re
select everything from scratch and
someone on so forth is gonna go ahead
and check quests on time of course but
that's gonna basically be it in a very
simple thing so let's try to go ahead
and do it now okay for any
the functionality this is boring and be
watch to click and get us some kind of a
pop-up like an inline pop off than
beginning inputs that we'll be able to
input the city name click integer then
the the actual applications is gonna go
ahead and change to that particular city
that's we have just chosen so I'm gonna
use some kind of library or third-party
components or decree for us which called
react popper that's allows you to easily
create pop-ups without a headaches or
something plus creating a pop-up says
it's quite hard thing to do it takes
quite a some time and it's not really is
that thing for doing it just from
scratch in this video so we can just go
in and use a third-party libraries
basically the best thing to do in this
in this case so it does the drop race
clean perfectly in here you can go ahead
and just install this react popper think
it's available and get hot with all the
things in here any users actually the
when do a prompt from reacts it's like
basically an awesome design pattern that
you can get ready to use we're just
gonna do this I'm gonna starve yes
proper and just save it so I just like
full documentation in here reacts proper
and you normally installer you can use
run whatever both of them are actually
working pretty much fine so it's pretty
simple pretty basic this is gonna do if
we jump to the weather application I
think inside of the top yeah there we go
we've got the button and you could take
a look in here and explaining the
definition of this or how actually worse
and how this design pattern works you've
got a manager in here that manages that
both the pop-up and the reference and
basically the reference is actually the
button that you talk like you click in
your shell of the pop-up and you
actually you know or your hover and you
show up the pop-up dislike hit the
toggle button all we want you in our
case is gonna be this we click in and we
want to show up the Popham button or the
actual pop-up container and we've got in
here you're basically gonna pass it a
function and you're gonna pass your
props from this reference so the river
is gonna pass your props in here they
can use this props in order to be able
to render this it's two really awesome
design
and also you can pass in another
function here passing you some kind of a
props like having a row prompts which
placement it is you put the basement of
course above here and what a style and a
reference then you can actually use and
you can just go ahead and put them all
inside of here and you can this
basically the container off your popper
or you too much pop up and you can just
go in and use it it's pretty basics not
that much of complicate or anything it
straight to the points so we can go
ahead and use this right now I'm gonna
go ahead and grab it from as they've
said in here I'm just gonna copy this
and when I waste so much of time so I've
got the manager the reference and the
popper and they need to rub both of
these inside of here I can also just go
ahead and copy all that it's just like
copy pasting is not read on much you're
complicated so we've got the reference
and you've got both of them we need you
to go ahead and inside of it instead of
putting this bone in I can cut this
button and you put it in here because
this is our toggle bottom that we wanted
to use and we've got just like a very
basic pop-up in here so we can go ahead
and test it and see how it works but
instead of the rice let me just put the
placement to the top so we can you know
better see this we've got the reacts
application I don't know I'm getting
putting two things in here two
completely different things to button
it's like I'm doing them both or
something and just might make sure to
put it the reference in here because
this is actually how the design pattern
work just with the reference you're
gonna allow it to reference denim and
get the actual exact location or that's
an exact position of your target button
in here and and this actually can help
it a lot so yeah just doing that that
can pretty much help a lot but what we
needed here is not gonna help us anyway
so so if they receive the layout is
pretty much working we get all that
stuff proper elements shows anyway so by
default it's visible for he wants is
only to show it or only make it visible
once we click the button so we toggle
this like they show up of this proper
elements only once we click the bodice
so we need to do it like a toggle system
so we're gonna go ahead and or click ill
here
so once we click it you're gonna just do
that and I've gots above this I'm gonna
create a private function or private
method since you are actually inside of
a class context I'm gonna need this on
select location okay let's let's try to
talk Oh try on Tobel selects location
and it's gonna take in events or
basically we're not gonna need that much
of an event anyway so yeah it's
basically basically where it is I felt
myself and much of the entire skill
that's why I put it to private sorry
guys
just like I work a lot with time skill
that's why I did prime it over there but
anyway so pretty just an on toggle
select location method up there and here
we won against the reference of that so
by default gonna have is selects
location open and right defaults gonna
be false so it's the startup is gonna be
false and here we're gonna do if or
we're just gonna do the set state and we
couldn't get the second version so we
get a previous state and we can actually
set a new state of this of this previous
state so we can do like is selects
location open and we just talked late
but I just I'm putting in falls to the
last stage so please select location
open and just doing the not in here will
reverse everything since of just a
boolean it's gonna do the job for us
perfectly and here we've gotta go ahead
and put this so I'm gonna save this
thought intellectual occasion our own
toggle select location and make sure to
bind the current class context by just
doing bind this it's a really important
thing to do inside of reacts either you
can do an inside of the constructor or
you can inline doing it here on the
event function both of them works so we
just like to prefer using it in online
events function and yeah this should do
a job perfectly normally to use this
variable so up here I need to go and
construct this variable from the
I'm gonna do is select options open
equals okay so is states there we go and
we're not gonna allow this to render so
I'm gonna do is select location location
open and so we're just gonna do an
operation here so it is true it's gonna
render if it is false it's not gonna
render anyway and this should do it real
firstly for us so we can go back I think
once you click this is previously we get
it wants to be click it again it just
like toggles everything so just like now
it looks much better as a pop-up we
still got a couple of things I should
you add like a sound you want to show
the proper cursor the hand cursor think
so I'm gonna do this where's the barn
actually so or we can do this a little
bit inside of the applause this is
because it's like Generic thing for all
the bodies I'm gonna do cursor to
pointer and yeah we should do a job I
want to think is I want to fix the
pop-up so we need to give it a quick
awesome style for this pop-up it's
really important thing to do so I'm
gonna do this really quick I'm gonna do
the width of odds I don't know let's try
my VM or something like this it's that's
okay that seems good okay for the hides
I'm gonna try five what seems decent and
I'm gonna do it display of flex okay
that sounds actually good I'm gonna do a
border radius four pixels and I'm gonna
add family background - color it's gonna
meet make a white background color so it
looks aesthetically rich in here
basically I'm gonna add some box shadow
like gonna 0 pixels your pixel just like
center it and it can have three pixels
in there for the blurred stuff so I can
3 pixels and you can add for example a
pig soul so egg
do RGB 15-15-15 just basically DARPA Dre
but with just a layer transparency in
here and I can actually take this down
yeah it looks much better now way much
better so it looks like a real word
pop-up so it better than it was
and it's basically doing the job
perfectly yeah I think putting the top
for the bottom
I could put some kind of top like this
so he gets the point perfectly and it
can put just like since it's an absolute
so you can easily play around with the
top of the left positions in here a lot
of your problems actually so yeah you
can get them do the job for you yeah so
this is basically it let's try now to
let me just change the font size we're
gonna just make it 16 pixels or
something like this okay let's just just
go in with 16 pixels no problem with
this let me copy that and put it inside
of a pop-up since we already start at
the top but the power is actually a
generic thing so we can go and put it
inside of the up top SSSs
it's like a common things you have
you're gonna do a pokémon - container
and it's gonna be the pop-up container
that's real guts then we can just go
back and reference the same style that
we have gods so where is that inside of
the top and couldn't words okay this is
gonna take class
[Music]
- - Jake
great can be back in here okay that's
that seems pretty decent actually so
yeah it's doing the job perfectly they
can take a little bit of the width and
the rosette the opto CSS can take the
top a little bit off like 60 or
something that should actually do the
job or I don't know I think it's being
overreaching that's why I'm not getting
it right but what I can do is I don't
know I'll just keep it for now like this
or we can play around with some CSS
styles in here like inline styles so we
can actually take that Oscar seriously
I'm putting the style in here and which
doing the job perfectly but I can put
another object inside of this and I can
put the top or it's not here the top
position - like a box - 55 pixels so he
goes it there a bit to the top and
hopefully does that but yeah I think
it's actually okay this is this is not
what I want to hear it's basically not
what it once so I need to put it inside
of this cell so this is basically the
the main solid I should have put it
inside of it
I just miss any curly brace and saving
that or is this okay
and basically now it works okay so I
don't know I don't like this 45 it could
work now for the 45 yeah it does it does
a great job okay
now the pop ups actually finished like
just trynna now to put inside of it some
input things so we can control this
pop-up in sort of this nifty text I can
input div and it's gonna be a class name
like form container and we're gonna have
some kind of label and ylabel HTML for
location or location name and you can
put in input its type text and we can
put an ID to this employer which can be
location a and yeah so placeholder or I
can put a little bit place order Monica
proceeding or right so you might wonder
if it's another better barn and it's
gonna it's gonna have the same style
this spot on it let me just gonna put it
the same style of it I don't want to do
a lot of things and selects
[Music]
take a look on a selection here it's
pretty much working fine without any
problems hopefully and we're doing it
actually in imports with some kind of a
placeholder we definitely need to add
some sounds to it because it's not gonna
look this very much stunning as we want
it to be as the labor and everything so
we can just go ahead and edit the style
just a tiny bit so it looks as we want
it to be like for the funds rush size
for a big Souls or something okay that
sounds good and also we can go ahead and
do some where is the form container or
you can do something padding for the
whole container like five pixels or even
more than five pixels six pixels okay
and for the input as well I'm gonna put
the width so we can take the cool with
out of this okay the input is actually
add some Porter
we used to add like four pixels or
something okay that's quite a lot so I'm
gonna do an also a border in pixels all
right RGBA
then change your point - but that's
decent actually it's not the greatest
thing the greatest input basically but
it should a job perfectly so we're
trying to go ahead now and stylus and
I'm gonna put it okay inside of the
upload CSS I'm going to just create a
form
- container and it's actually inside the
input so put an input gonna put it there
I'm gonna have a label
I'm also it's gonna have a custom style
that I've just set for it so it's just a
font size
just a tiny font size and we've got also
some kind of a custom styles for the
main container which is the form
container
and well it's actually doing it and the
try not to go into the pop-up container
and take this fix at Heights I should do
the job perfectly for now or we can just
take it out ourselves like 55 p.m. is is
basically perfect value problems and we
can take the width and now it looks much
much more stunning and it was looking I
don't know what it could advance it's
versus actually so we think it's kind of
a pop-up container they've put it in
here yeah I actually did it completely
for God's so just facing this saving it
and there we go we've got we've got
that's pretty decent not reads that much
of awesome things but it should do the
job perfectly and since we've got an
absolute position so once you change
that it actually changes with you but
just refer to the application it's gonna
work so yeah I don't know what I'm
getting this but it's ridiculous I think
the problem that I'm in doing is if I go
to the top is I'm actually overriding
the data which you shouldn't have done
but I'm stupid enough to do so yeah you
gotta points I shouldn't have done
that's just leave it as it is you can
just go and use some CSS styles to
offset this but I'm just gonna leave it
as it is for now it works pretty much 5
than your problems so there we see it's
pretty great now we need to add some
functionality to it like whenever we
click that I'm gonna change the like we
click select it changes the whole thing
for this and I actually can when it
click outside it can't close this it's
really annoying thing but you can work a
little bit on that so you can you can
fix it
that's not really a big deal to be
taking care of but it's still a thing to
do for your application so now how we
can think about whenever you click the
select button which is going to be this
button you're gonna hook up something so
we're going to just like
do an event or something like emits and
events it's actually gonna take care of
doing and refreshing the whole thing
changing the state and actually sending
another request to the API for getting
another city and so on and so forth so
for basically doing this what we can do
is use event imager but I've put it
inside of a flock so remember the first
time that we have set up the storage and
I've told you that it's gonna be our
flocks store so we were actually
combining together components so as a
child component it's kind of rough and
hard from a child component in react
ecosystem from a child component talking
with appearance components that's in the
hierarchy this is actually really
ridiculous to do but using a flocks like
a parent comparative flocks or even
Redux for a higher-end application on
larger projects but for now just flux is
doing pretty much job for us great job
for our application learning problems
actually so we can just send the DN a--
from the child back to the actual parent
component without any problems and we
can use for this case something called
events and events imagers so i can
actually go ahead and create something
like this so what i'm gonna do inside of
this store i'm gonna go ahead and grab
this events going to events
immature bomb so the events actually a
module created for you by default
install for you from no GS so it's like
a pre build smarter at the standard
mario or no genius so once you actually
use npm install the packages you're
gonna find it by default install for you
inside of the node module so you don't
really have to install it even though
you don't have it you can just go in and
install it but most of the times 100%
you're gonna find it over there so you
don't really need to require an install
anything and yes this is basically why
you should just be taken care of now
inside of here instead of the stage we
can save some kind of an event imager
then we can use actually this objects so
instead of a constructor not a state
actually
just inside of the constructs I'm gonna
create an instance of that I'm gonna do
this thoughts events immature it's not a
couple keys because it's just that
object instead so that I'm gonna do a
new of events imager just creating these
simple instance of this and this
actually when you take a look on it you
can do event or image your Dom not
accessing the actual objects so events
image your dots you're gonna find a
couple of methods like the most
important for us is the immense method
that allows you to actually emits an
event to the whole registered callbacks
and listeners and inside of the on
method your should register your
listeners for a specific events names
and events keys and stuff so we can use
this to actually the parent is gonna
play the role of a listener that
listeners for a specific event to be
fired up and from the child components
we can just go in and fire up this
events we can pass him some data that we
can actually use in a specific channel
or that the parents are saying that
gonna meet in our case is gonna need
actually the city name so we can pass
him from the child to the parent and he
can actually give the data and refresh
the whole things that the states and
stuff like this let's try to go that and
as I've told you whenever you try to
render this I'm gonna pass in the event
immature all the way down to all those
children's so this is gonna be the case
thing in here I'm gonna do it right over
here
so we cloned the elements we're gonna
just pass in the state but alongside of
the state I'm gonna do this dots or I'm
gonna name something event immature and
I'm gonna pass in the event immature you
can just go ahead and pass in only the
on and the emit events if you really
perform a splendid don't really pass all
the things into the hierarchy of the
children but it's okay for now for our
application and it's gonna help us a lot
for a performance and stuff so it's not
really a big deal to be taken care of
now we can just jump since the up
thought genetics is this next thing is
gonna be rendered so we sort of is that
this top prompts so remember it's gonna
be passed through all the prompts in
here we're gonna get something like
event or imager has the reference of the
objects that we have created up there
and actually we can get that really
easily in here where's this okay so once
we get it let me just think for a second
where we gonna use this I'm gonna use
instead of the top section so here I'm
expecting to get from the props it's
sort of a render I'm gonna do just to
expect that we're gonna get is it like
an events where is that immature and
it's going to be this top props but
basically I don't think I'm gonna use it
in here anyway so just expect that we
have is this way and we can just go in
and past this I'm gonna do the events
immature equals this Dom profs those
events
immature remember that's we have just
passive from there or so yeah it's
clearly the way that we should do that
we're gonna give this event imagery but
we in first need you to register a
callback once we click the select button
we're gonna get to the data that is
inside of this input and how we can do
that that's I'm gonna talk about this in
a second let me just gonna first AB on a
click callback in light of this I'm
gonna need this for example I'm gonna do
this dot on select city
I don't select say okay just keep it
like this I'm gonna point this should
wear okay I'm gonna add it this boundary
to it and it's gonna be selects and
everything hopefully so we can align it
now on select City it's gonna take an
advantage and everything don't really
care about the events and we actually
need to go ahead and do another method
on city name and change or on location
name change so this can actually updates
every single time go ahead and update
the state and this is going to take it
events so it's gonna be a change event
from reacts and every single time we
update the inputs this change events
gonna be fired up and we can go ahead
and update the stage with a new value
that's we've got from the input and I'm
gonna have it
Vincent here so on location in change
I'm gonna find the actual this pullback
okay and as I've told you it's gonna get
basically an event in here that's really
change so I'm gonna basically just go in
and do this thoughts set the states city
name or let's go ahead and do its
location name it's gonna be a dot charge
its and I'm just gonna fetch the value
from the target target is actually
representing the actual HTML and input
elements so it's the reference of it and
we can just access the value of a the
current value of it as the mean time of
receiving this particular events and we
just go ahead and just do with this set
state and we save that basically with on
your problems now hopefully you should
work but now we're actually gonna guess
the location name like this text is
going to be saved inside of the vocation
nameless state so let me just go and do
this represented here and I'd be
location in this top states and what I'm
gonna do I'm going to use the events
imagery that it gets from the props I
can also go and in the reference ass so
event imager is gonna be poses dog props
remember that I've just passed this into
it I'm gonna do this immature dots and
here we're going to emit an event
remember you're gonna imagine events I'm
gonna give it a name off or let me just
do updates weather so updates weather it
basically is I'm gonna hear what's there
now what type of data you want to pass
it through I'm gonna just go ahead and
pass in a defense or the actual city
named as we have gone to a location name
so remember it's gonna be location aid
and that basically it's now up with the
hierarchy on the up dog ax remember the
alcoholics is actually the main
component that is responsible for
fetching the DNA and doing the states
and doing all the changes and stuff like
this so what we can actually go ahead
and do is just going and
do like components dip mouch will
gesture the eventlistener phrase so I'm
gonna just right below this I'm gonna go
and register the events emitter from
this top prop so okay I can rip this
down so we event immature is gonna equal
this top props and down here event
immature I'm gonna list you for any
events for a specific events name is
gonna be where is this update weather
okay it's gonna be a callback so here
we're gonna guess the actual data that
we want which is gonna be just gonna
leave it data there's gonna be a waste
so we need to access the first step of
the data so I'm just gonna go in and do
a console log of the DN a-- or location
name so to make sure that everything is
too much working fine and I'm gonna just
do DN a-- the zeroth value and this will
actually return an object and i'm gonna
access okay let me location name so it's
basically the api of how the image
events imagery works it returns or it
gives you in here is inside of this
callback is gonna give you an array of
all of the DN a-- so if you try not here
to pass and multiple things you can do
it so remember the first one is going to
be the zero index and the other one is
gonna be this the first index in someone
and so forth so since we only happen one
is still gonna be in a way anyway but we
need to access the first index of it
will fetch that and it's gonna return
objects of all of the anodize inside of
that and we can just governor fish
location name pretty simply but let me
just get rid of that so i'm not pretty
sure that's gonna be in objects anyway
but let's just go ahead and see compiled
let's go into here and we can try to you
know take a look on just give it a quick
look
what is this update weather component
the amounts let me see this
i don't know kind of something not
working and yeah it can you can't not
actually read the property on undefined
for some reason the component the amount
is not actually getting the events
imager
from the umph that we are rendering let
me take a look on the inductor GS we
were rendering the up okay that's that's
a kind of problem I didn't do that I
talked about the store we created the
store and everything so remember that
we've created store and we meant to use
the store like a flux store so we've got
to use the store as a wrapper to render
the application but we didn't do that
anyway so I'm actually fool or something
while I try to go in and fix our what we
did we can just go ahead reference the
store we give the store then we can
instead of the up in here we need to use
the wrapper so it's likely to work as we
expected it to be so it's gonna be the
wrapper of things in here and now
hopefully you should work if you jump in
back in here we take a look on the
console log we're not getting anything
since I haven't done anything yes try to
put some city name for example gonna put
I don't know Paris or something okay try
to click select and there we go we've
got the location name there we go this
location name but even though that's we
only get in the P for some reason we're
not getting curse we're just getting the
first character so that's pretty nifty
as well let me just check that again
just getting P that's really ridiculous
I think the problem here is not passing
away or something I don't understand
that but the last time you used this it
was passing you're a believer in hot
spots right now all the sudden it does
decided not to pass in array I put it
Paris again selects and there we go I've
got Paris so just ignore my what I said
it won't pass an array or something I
don't know I'm so confused you can just
go in and check out the documentation
but this is basically how he works now
it works we tested it and everything is
pretty much working fine we can just go
ahead and do the whole process but the
whole process is a little bit confusing
and it's gonna take us quite some time
so we can just copy this old code and
ugly thing and we can just put in in
here and so on and so forth which is not
what we want so what we can do instead
is actually just
go ahead and set the stage and
everything's gonna be we render it for
us and we can put is gonna check but in
this case we only put it this like the
components they mount so only when he
tries to mount or something it's not
gonna be like as clearly see if we could
take a look on documentation call
immediately after components mounted
saying stayed here will trigger every
rendering only are we rendering but
nothing completely different so let's
try not go ahead to set the state's
enough talking I'm gonna do such stage
I'm gonna change the city name you think
it may be a city okay I can put city
name and I can put the theater so
basically where it is try to see if that
works
must we click we input this new city
name and we click select location does
it can I go ahead and change the
location naming we fresh for that I'm
not quite sure I'll just go ahead and
try to test this I'm gonna say Paris
selects and there we go we've we've got
that actually so I've got Paris we've
got everything updated basically pairs
as well as it's actually at night we
might want to choose something
completely different like California or
something so to see a difference I don't
know I don't know how to spell
California or something but yeah it's
actually updating California but it's
not updating something like the Celsius
so degrees and it will be updating the
city name for some reason so yeah as
I've told you there's not as we expected
it to be so we need to move on this
logics from here to a completely
different things so we can just go and
create a function for it and once we hit
that you can just go ahead and fire up
this function so I'm gonna do a function
updates
the weather and this update weather is
I'm just gonna tell you that's the whole
thing of it I'm gonna paste it here I'm
just gonna copy that as well just all
need it up there
so there's city name and everything and
I need to call this every single time
that we want to update the video so
firstly initially by default once we get
into the application without receiving
any events or something we want to
update this so it gets the initial thing
I'm gonna do updates weather and
actually after putting this dot state
and we said the city and we said
actually the data now we've gotta go in
and update it so we call this da update
whether the the method that's we have to
discrete it up there so what it does
just gonna go ahead and grab this URL
updated it does the get request and
everything and later on it sets the
stage and updates every single thing so
this is what probably should do after
sending the city name so it takes the
city new city name from there any
updated with this but actually there's
one single problem with this sheshu
we're thinking about remember that's
reacts when he said to the state
everything's gonna be a synchronous so
when asynchronous code is gets executed
you can't actually know if the sister is
gonna be first
although update whether it's gonna be
first executed so yeah this is really
confusing so you've got to go ahead and
use the callback to help you that and
likely this dot point state or the sense
state method gives us that and it
provides you with a callback so you can
just go ahead and use this why you can
do with this callback is actually what
the state has been sent and updated
successfully you can just go ahead and
call this update weather and this will
problem pretty much gonna go ahead in
here just by cutting the update weather
and we're gonna go ahead and put this as
the second parameter so that set state
methods takes the second parameter which
is a callback that gets executed after
the state has been set successfully so
it's a normal compac gonna use weather
or a row callback in here I mean just
like update the weather and once the
city name has been updated with the data
we can just go ahead and
you know update the weather so the
weather can know about the changes have
been made to the city name that was
really important it's very using it in
the update weather method and we're
distracting that and we're doing the
whole rig you want whole thing we're
including this data and on it
it's really important to ensure first
that city name has getting updated on
the state then later on we can just go
ahead and down you know gets the data
and fetch it from the AP on etsy.com or
something the API our risk for API and
then we can just govern an update now
let me just get rid of that and we'll
really need it and save so it compiles
that hopefully now if you can take a
look the set state is actually gonna do
the job and the update weather pretty
much what gets executed of the state has
been successfully set so there will be
no problems and you can just go ahead
and refresh that's Leo's the weather we
wait for it now we first need to try to
set the state and for example California
we can go in and do select as you
clearly see behind the scenes each
changed it changing the icon update a
baby degrees think also the the city
name has been updated and all obviously
the text that we have call either
everything has been updated now the
actual way that we have thought about
has been working actually very fine with
all your problems you cannot use another
thing or something
by using this but why now I'm thinking
is actually when you give this pop-up
you click the select button and actually
the pop-up can it be hard automatically
so try to add that so we go into the
index top component of the top section
components and I need to actually find
it in the on click method so the pop-up
container in here what's gonna happen is
actually hi did once we select the
container so when we do that hopefully
we can go ahead and use this so we can
put is select options open and you can
put this to false so once we click the
select button it's just gonna go ahead
and false that's that's pretty much
we're gonna do in here just me just go
ahead and select that here we see a
London and this is London thing is gonna
get it's by default because we have in
this inside of our state and it's
sitting there by default you can go
ahead and change that by default or
better thing to do is actually you can
get the location of the curve
user this is actually what most of the
weather application gonna do and to do
this in other browsers a little bit
tricky so you've gots to get the
permission for the getting the location
of stuff you can go ahead and do it
using the JavaScript API it's not a big
deal or something you can find a third
by libraries saying they're an NPM and
you can go and use it very easily but I
think what I'm talking about is getting
the weather now try to select them in
here as clear see but we've got a box so
I think I've thought or I put it this in
the wrong place
yeah I shouldn't put that on select
location name change so actually need to
find select city so there we go this is
the method that we want to you know hide
the pop-up so we can go in and do this
top set States and actually we can put a
selection pop-up opening which is just
set it folds this is basically what we
wants once we select the city or
Tomatoes say once we push the button we
do that and actually we have to omit the
event before that so refreshing just
wait for this and I don't know I'm
having two instances of this now try it
again California once we can select that
there we go the pop-up gonna be
automatically hidden for us and this is
a really awesome user experience so this
is actually what you should be doing
care about better thing or better user
experience you can have like a close
button instead of the pop-up in you can
just go and let the use your exit the
pop-up you know the time doesn't allow
us to do so so you can just go ahead and
ignore this and you let me change it to
four days because this is gonna use
instead of five days it's quite a lot so
I'm just gonna go in and try to work on
the bottom section and try to display up
to four days of forecast so from today
and the next four days and we can just
go in and do this so the bottom section
we try to do and inside of the container
like you know and the ending div or the
closing tag of that and we try to the
bottom container but actually here what
we first need to do is actually gives
another component that gets rendered so
obviously what you need to do is get the
forecast day which is like an array and
basically just go ahead and use a math
function it's basically a for loop and
look on each one of them and return that
so we can easily render them so I'm
going to add a new component
got a name it's you know forecast date
JSX and there's gonna render a single
forecast date and we're gonna have four
forecast days gonna be rendering it
their theories see here have an array so
I'm gonna simply just type in import
react from react this is an usual thing
for creating a components and we can go
in and export a default like forecasts
on a day or you can use these or
something in his I don't know let's go
ahead and just put it like this way
non-capital or and we can extend the
components simply you're just creating a
normal class components so can structure
the props and super with props to since
we're going to need the props in this
case because we're gonna passing the
data inside of the props and this data
is gonna be actually the forecast day DN
a so we're gonna get this and actually
we use the render to return the actual
structure of this so if we can take a
look I've got on here like a simple
container that's you know shows the the
forecast day that we can actually copy
the CSS code from figma seriously in
here the lock right side and we can for
example display the degrees and show up
an image or simply just show up the text
in there for example it's cloudy or
sunny or you know something like this or
overcast or anything like that so we can
jump back in here let's try now to go
ahead and render damp with a class name
and for example gonna put forecast day -
container so it's gonna be luckily the
container for the for the whole thing
that's gonna be in the side of that we
can have another day which is gonna be
the image so it's gonna be the container
all the image and we can have another
one which is a try something like text
okay so you're gonna be image and text
and here we're gonna test with an image
so simply you can just go in and put an
image let me just go back in here and
try to copy the URL for this just for
testing purposes that's totally before
you always need to just your you know
your code your components that gets
rendering something then you can in
integrator in
okk them with api's so yeah they Piazza
the dynamic data comes at the end you
can put Sun either now we can jump I
don't know the forecast a container here
can jump to those style.css for the
bottom which is actually sort of the
bottom can put an image and this is the
image actually the class name and you
can have also the text which is also a
class name in here with the main
container for the text we're gonna put
I'm gonna have an image tag since it's
gonna have an image tag or we see the
width they're gonna be hundred percent
relatively gonna take the full width and
the full height of the main container
which is the image container here we can
have for example I don't know let's look
on the size of this I just want to make
it a little bit smaller than the the top
section images we have got in there so I
don't know trial for with about 2m and
Heights exactly 2 a.m. and that sounds
these things for the text you might
wanna set the font size okay the try
font size or yeah okay font size about
so try 12 pixels okay that should be T
since like 12 pixels and we can save
that now we've got to go ahead and use
the components and actually rendering
but before so we've got a first it gets
the data from the main application what
do you mean by DNA is actually gets when
we fetch the data from the RESTful API
we are pretty much gonna pass this DN
a-- as a prop to the bottom container
then actually on the bottom container we
can go ahead do a for loop as i've told
you or a map function and it's actually
gonna use a map function because one
reacts when you try to loop an array
you've gotta use map functions so we can
jump back in here
seriously we need to go into the plot
gsx in here and once we update the
weather API we've gotta put another data
for the forecasting so let me get your
name forecast days it's gonna be an away
as we have seen in there since we are
already getting in array so it's
basically ants we're gonna just save on
the state and away completely seen here
we've got the forecast then of
for Cassidy's which is Anna ready yes
we're gonna just save that so we've got
a first access theater forecast and
forecast these okay so yeah that that
should be actually is and we just
actually access the objects as we are
gonna get now on the bottom section we
can go in and pass the amounts of props
so we can do forecast days equals this I
don't know we can use the describe this
structure let me just put that first and
I can copy this and just put in the
state in here like we've got a de
structure yeah I've got already the
state in here and what I'm doing but so
of course I need to put forecast days or
I basically need the forecast days with
with no caps will be in the middle but
yeah actually you think I have some kind
of a name convention but okay nevermind
I'm gonna just put that and now what we
expecting inside of the bottom section
components actually we're gonna distract
this from the props so the forecast days
and simply we're gonna do this top
prompts so now we can take this and
remember we've got an Iranian side of
that let me first just import the new
components which is going to be the
forecast day components from from the
file s we have just created so okay
there we go
just import that and simply you've got
an array in here inside of array there's
a couple of objects each objects gonna
represent a single day on the forecast
so once you request something like five
or something we requesting four you're
gonna give this exact four days inside
of the forecast so yeah it's pretty
simple
let me just gonna change this because
it's a little bit annoying so the naming
convention I'm gonna change it to four
and of course I've got like four castes
let me change it to numb four castes so
it's a little bit much better for a name
of convention because we've got another
variable in States name the same theme
like for castes which is an array we
don't really want to put that so you
already have two now to name your
variables because that's a really
important thing when dealing with an
application especially if it's a large
or a complicated project things I mean
component is nested inside of each
others try to look in here so we're
gonna do just the four castes in here
and so I've got to first wrap this I
can't do that so we've gotta go in and
do like the escape inside of the GSX
and here instead of the malfunction
we're gonna get a cold bag that gets
cold with the each element out of the
array so you can just remember or take
this on so for loop even though you can
use a for loop inside of a gsx to render
things so the only way to render an
array and loop on each item and render
that each item context so you've gotta
use a map function so this is basically
one map functions exist in es6 and they
are very powerful a lot of people use
them so we can get days to index now
we've gotta go in and do it's just like
a one return each component or for each
object inside of that just return a new
component which is gonna be the
forecasting so remember that it's
actually takes a couple of data from the
props so I'm gonna go in and past hey
let me just gonna you know I need to
make this dynamic so we can go ahead and
use this but for now I was gonna try to
use this for testing purposes and it
should pretty much work fine I just put
the key and the key actually gonna tell
react how to organize things especially
use them inside of a map so they're all
gonna be stacked above each others and
the key can let react differentiate
between them and it allow us to optimize
the application and the rendering
process and now it's actually Lee odden
well I think it's kind of a stark or
something I don't know it's taking quite
some time actually oh the weather and
they stuck on the layout in weather
screen try to fresh that take a look
make look on that and there we go we've
got actually in error so the error says
it's actually on the bottom container
I've got cannot be properly map of
undefined so if for some reason the
forecast is is actually in defined
let me just take a look on that so we
think that props now are being passed
and defined and everything is actually
working fine here but yeah I think so
we're just gonna try to use an end in
here so to make sure that's only render
this only acts as the math function once
the forecast day is actually available
otherwise don't access it so it's really
important to do so on a react
application especially when using a
loading you know screen or something
like this the props not gonna be loaded
or when you actually use the rest for
EPS this really helps so the try I think
it's not working it's still stuck some
reason and there's actually kind of a
really annoying error in here take a
look in the ears and I see clearly see
so the weight data from the API cannot
be properly forecasted and defined okay
so we've got some kind of an error and
our API that's we're trying to parse the
JSON data that we are getting from the
restful api and I think I'm feeling
looking pretty much fine in here but
when we set the data the forecast I
think I'm missing in Ian here and so the
forecast I'm a misspelling or forecast
okay that's that's actually pretty great
I'm misspelling that I'm forgetting in
the middle so I'm just gonna put
forecast a here just fix that I'm gonna
fix that as well but key that's we were
saying is out of the states also we're
gonna go ahead and then just fix our
state's fix that on the bottom container
and pretty much the bottom section also
we can fix that all over the way on all
the components in here
now that should do pretty much the job
because it's just like you know the
syntax error nothing more nothing less
and but okay try refresh that's it ever
get something there we go we've got
we've got actually a really Olson thing
so it's like sunny sunny sunny but all
of them are structured or put it like in
a vertical line so it getting the data
but not perfectly so yeah it's not
perfect as we want it and also if I'm
having a static data in here so it's not
really that much what we want we need to
change this and make it look much better
on the side component in here but
as I've said she working pretty much
fine as far as I can see in here and we
need to structure that and fix the style
a little bit so it looks a bit more
awesome you can change the background in
there like you can you can find a really
better background but this is doing it
jump okay now try to use this and try to
fix the style so I'm gonna put a display
flex for the for the actual container
the main container the forecast date
container I'm gonna use flexbox it's a
great way for dealing with your elements
I'm gonna do flex direction I'm gonna
keep them Killian row for reason I'm
gonna put a justified contents in Center
and I'm gonna put all slowly aligned now
seems like you're gonna like align them
vertically and horizontally so line it
in Center I'm gonna do the job perfectly
hopefully you know for that we're
actually getting them centered
horizontally but not vertically and
they're not displayed in a row so for
some reason that that's not actually
happening as we want it to be so there's
clearly some issue in our style and you
have to go in and fix that so um yeah
that that's really a little bit annoying
let's try to add another inner container
so it's gonna be working as an inner
container that wraps all of the data
that we have got in there it's always
better to add an inner container inside
of your main container which is in this
case the bottom container so this inner
container could hold the data or
whatever you're into especially when
you're using a map and rendering an
array and loop it through it so we can
put the style in here make it like wraps
the whole image and the text and
everything we can move all the display
flexus out of that and let me just make
the width and the full height so from
the forecast container and pretty much
this should do the job perfectly for us
for taking the full width and the full
heights also the inner container I don't
know that seems a little bit compromised
it's taking the full height actually so
actually a lot of height
taking it but still not discipline as we
want it to be so let me just double
check that the best way is I hate to use
it in his specs and I'm gonna just dive
into the hierarchy of the rendering and
then take a look on our element try to
fix the systems it looks like all of
them are taking the full width and the
full heights for each forecast they near
each forecast container and that is not
what we exactly want her to do that
seems a little bit of a misunderstanding
if we try to do in here and also the
inner container is actually taking the
full width for some reason so that seems
a little bit annoying okay let's take a
look on the stop CSS and I don't know
that that's a little bit weird I've got
all of that okay that I totally forgot
about that so I'm just gonna take the
inner container and put it up because it
doesn't belong it's on the forecast they
can change so it actually belongs inside
the bottom container that that's my bad
it's not a child a child on the forecast
made container instead it's a child of
the bottom container and you completely
misunderstood that's now it somehow
looks a little bit as we wanted but not
exactly there's still a couple of things
to do and yeah we actually need to put
them in a century but they're not
perfectly centered and I think the
problem is let's let me take a look
that's so for with some of you I think
the problem is we just put in the full
width and the full height but the
forecast containers each one of them is
taking the full with the full height let
me just try to put none iTunes to Center
and to completely censor them
I'm not putting display flex there
that's clearly annoying we tried working
with the styles so each one of these are
taking the fool with why once it's
actually to Center them so that's a
little bit off when it comes to dealing
with the CSS styles and rendering
Indiana from an array and trying to take
care of that let's try now to like you
know hook up the API and they try to PAP
push or you know pretty much push the
props I'm gonna name this day I'm gonna
call it day I'm just gonna pass in the
day to the to the actual forecast now we
can change from the static test put it
and we could use actually other props
from from a dynamic theater of gods from
the restful api and that should do the
job Berkeley's we're gonna get the day
and here we also need to change the
static image with static icon to let me
take a look on that the temporary we've
got an average temporary so we can use
this so we can do on a date Dodd's
average temporary you can use a max or a
minimum temporary buts okay that's
that's pretty decent if you're just
gonna it using every temporary there's a
plenty of Thea you can go into render
but they're just going to make it simple
for now you can also go to the condition
we can grab the icons so I'm gonna
access icon and yeah let's try to
refresh that's okay this there's
actually nothing being displayed on the
API in like we are getting nothing so
let me just double check that it looks a
little bit like there's something wrong
with us
the other condition is actually met
missing and here for the average
temperature yeah we've got an error like
the dot condition dot icon it cannot
access the property of and defined and
they think there's a problem when it
comes to props and since we are using
Lee odden
but I don't know I think gonna return
and know if there's no day and if
actually the day has been received and
in the final just gonna return no so
we're not gonna render anything because
the risk for APR hasn't hasn't you know
sent a response back to us and hasn't
responded anyway with a DN a-- that we
need so therefore we might use that but
taking a look is out of this the
condition seems fine and yeah i think
we've got a day unless we were missing
actually so we need to access the day
property which is the object that
holding all this theater so we can do
this in here like data or you can just
go back and here we say de da de and
actually we can pass in the current day
so I mean the objects of the day so it
hasn't objects of the day and it has all
a couple of things like the day time and
stuff like this and there we go it works
pretty much now we get the icon it gets
the you know the average temperature
just getting like a little bit like a
floating point or a double point but
that's not really big new you can go and
change it or you can like you know shelf
both the minimum temperature in maximum
temperature and let me try to fix or
play around with the CSS Alvin here so
hopefully he'll fix that's and the width
is actually you know taking the full
width in the full height let me just try
the first 3 a.m. or something
just give it a custom width and custom
height I'm gonna go ahead okay so I was
taking the full with her full height
both of them being aligned I don't know
some reason it's not working the try to
put display flex just to find content to
the center and also align the items to
the center there we go now we've got
them actually perfectly aligned because
they wouldn't unlined
as we want them to be inside of the
forecast container and he wasn't
actually putting a flex or a display
flex that's that's my bad and this is
the problem if God's and now you should
pretty much do the job perfectly the
children's try to copy that and let me
just you know take this a little bit up
the actual
that's a copy the CSS styles can go in
sort of okay the forecast container can
just overwrite all the data and now we
should work be much fun so take a look
in here try I don't know let me take a
look and put a color in here ffff
because the color is not exactly
matching as we want it to be
since the background is not the best
thing for this dark grey color and all
the white color might look a little bit
better but we still we need to upgrade
or take the width of the height of the
image it's a little bit up that's quite
a lot so it can take you 3.2 muttering
this that's still ridiculously I know a
lots just three would do the job okay
and there we go
that seems much much more interesting
than it was and actually displays
everything perfectly gets the forecast
and he gets everything you know the API
is working we can actually pass the
props you can add another one which is
gonna name is for example muted text and
this one gonna have actually the text
for your for your day for example sunny
or cloudy or somebody that's like the
condition of that so you can put the
condition dot text inside of this and I
can I can you know make sure that's it's
like exactly inside of a condition now
we can go in here add the class of muted
text and we can add on the font size of
this it's gonna be as put 12 and see the
color is gonna be okay they try
something like a little bit darker than
the FFF or something I'm trying to call
the color picker and there we go we've
got the color picker now and try to
figure out something like darker gray
not completely wide spots something that
good to do the job try this okay let's
take a look on the style yeah we've got
we've got the dark grey but it's not
looking great as we expect it to be so
they're gonna try to change it back to
the white
just completely whites FFF okay that
does the job every now and let me just
take this down to ten pixels and yeah
that sounds pretty great so ten pixels
does the job perfectly and the style now
with God's is actually pretty cool so
yeah everything seems to be nice
we've got the icons we've got the
weather you can just go ahead and as
I've said you can put the current
location in everything gonna be
automated for you but a clock on the
Aptos ass in here I'll let me just take
the hundreds of the application so it
looks way much better there we go now it
looks like much much better with the
image in the background and you know the
forecasts of the days and the weather
the courage weather all the information
always listed and that's pretty much it
for the weather application that was
actually pretty basic thing just want to
point you guys to creating a weather
application hopefully actually enjoyed
the video tutorial um I put in later so
you can go in and check out my channel
down in the description you're gonna
find the code in the repository and get
hop you can also find the link in
description below so it's I think it
computer to freaking curve so hopefully
you liked it if you like more videos
like this let me know in the comments
and we'll be very happy to do so and
yeah also you can just go ahead and
check out our pants comm with really
awesome stories much more stories like
that and yeah so I think also watching
this was it again hopefully guys who
have enjoyed that and see you will
hopefully in another video tutorials
like this